die
إ
의
l
Ich gebe zu, ungewöhnliche Zeit, montags 13.50 Uhr, da müsst ihr wahrscheinlich noch
arbeiten gehe ich mal von aus, aber da kann man nichts machen. Wann kommt die
Top Level Domain POG ein, das ist eine gute Frage. Gibt es gibt es POG als Top Level Domain?
.pog..pog. Okay wir haben dort Poker,.porn,.pog, aber nicht.pog. Also da wird's
wirklich mal Zeit, wie macht man das eigentlich? Wie kann man eine neue Top Level Domain beantragen?
Ich brauche.pog. Anscheinend nicht so einfach. Anscheinend ist das nicht so easy. Wo bloß
.pog hätte ich beantragt. Aber das wirklich habe ich mich noch nie mit beschäftigt. Wie man
eigene eine eigene Top Level Domain beantragt. Okay das kann nicht jeder daher gelaufene Kacknut
machen. Also.pog für mich beantragen ist anscheinend nicht so ohne weiteres wirklich,
sehe ich gerade. Gut hätte ich jetzt auch nicht anders mit gerechnet. Ich meine,
wenn jeder daher gelaufene Volldepp irgendwelche Top Level Domains beantragen könnte,
dann hätte man ziemlich viel schnell voll. Ne, begünstigt ist es mit Sicherheit auch nicht.
Ach easy, guck mal hier. 200.000 Euro, was machen die denn bitteschön? Ich kann einen eigenen DNS
Server machen und die Domain, ja das geht. Das Problem ist nur, niemand anderes der Welt benutzt
meinen DNS Server. Immerhin könnte ich dann meinen.pog verwenden. Und jeder von euch,
der meinen DNS Server eingetragen hat, kann auch.pog auflösen.
Ne, das ist anscheinend eher nicht so easy mit eigener Top Level Domain. Naja,
machste nix. Pippo please.
So. Was? Wieso mit Wireshark oder was? Das ist bestimmt äußerst. Not Pog.
Also, heute machen wir was anderes. Und zwar, mir ist aufgefallen, dass ich mittlerweile,
was hab ich denn, um die 7 Domains oder so habe und ich ehrlich gesagt nirgendswo überprüfe,
ob die Dinge abgelaufen sind oder bald ablaufen oder so. Bei einigen habe ich Auto Renew auch
nicht eingeschaltet, weil ich mir nicht sicher bin, ob ich die behalten will. Und aus diesem
Grund ist mir heute Morgen beim Wandern eingefallen, es wäre nicht verkehrt, wenn ich diese Domains
irgendwie überwachen würde, ob die denn demnächst ablaufen. Weil ich meine, stelle euch mal vor,
ich will pricechamp.org noch länger behalten und ich weiß nicht, ob die ablaufen. So,
da gibt es verschiedene Möglichkeiten. Ich zeige euch mal, was die einfachste Variante wäre. So,
man könnte ein Whois machen auf pricechamp.org und dann erkennt, dann steht hier sowas drin,
wie registry expiry date. Aber das Problem ist jetzt, das geht nicht bei allen Domains. Wenn
ihr zum Beispiel das mal bei maxfps.de probiert, dann werdet ihr feststellen, das geht nicht.
Das heißt, den brauchen wir dafür aber nicht. Wir bauen einen eigenen Exporter. So, weil das
funktioniert nicht. So, ich bin gerade dabei, alle meine Domains zu... Ja, die ist noch auf Nitrado,
Alter. Die ist tatsächlich noch auf Nitrado, ja. So, ich bin gerade dabei, alle meine Domains umzuziehen
auf Cloudflare. Weil Cloudflare, ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob man das öffentlich sich angucken kann.
Nop, anscheinend nicht. Weil Cloudflare relativ günstig ist und überall gut unterstützt wird.
Und Cloudflare hat nichts dagegen, wenn man Fake-Taten einträgt, das juckt die nicht. So,
also. Dementsprechend bin ich gerade dabei, alles auf Cloudflare umzuziehen, meine ganzen Domains.
Ja, ich habe zum Beispiel so schöne Domains wie zum Beispiel kappalull.com, wer das schon
mal interessiert hat. Also wer schon immer mal wissen wollte, wem kappalull.com gehört, die ist
mir. Und die liegt bei Cloudflare. Danke für den Sub. Radiant Tracer, nee. Radiant Racer. Ja,
du, Cloudflare ist teilweise billiger als Namecheap. Also ich bezahle bei Cloudflare für eine
.com Domain ungefähr. Das ist eine gute Frage. Ich guck mal kurz, sage ich dir. Moment. Kappalull.com
kostet aktuell. Weiß nicht, das kann ich. Geil, steht net dabei. Ja, das nimmt sich alles nicht
viel. Google Domains, Google Domain, Namecheap und aber Cloudflare ist an sich ziemlich gut,
weil Cloudflare überall supportet wird. Wartet mal, ich sag euch, was bei Cloudflare der Kram
kostet. Domain Name, kappahdull.com. Gucken wir mal. Hallo? Aus Gründen, die sich mir nicht
erschließen, mag Cloudflare bei mir gerade keine Domain abfragen. Also, 8,50 Euro kostet es bei
Cloudflare. Weiß gar nicht, ob Cloudflare macht Cloudflare auch DE Domains. Kann ich meine
DE Domain überhaupt zu Cloudflare umziehen? Oder machen die das nicht? Das wäre ziemlich
dumm, weil ich will alle meine Domains zu Cloudflare umziehen. Ich glaube, Cloudflare kann
Cloudflare umziehen.
Wie gesagt, ihr müsst immer nach der gleichen Toplevel Domain gucken. DE Domains sind tatsächlich
relativ günstig. Egal, da soll es jetzt heute nicht darum gehen. Ich hoffe, ich kann meine
ganzen Domains zu Cloudflare umziehen. Aber mit den DE Domains muss man gucken. Schauen
wir mal. Also, wer wirklich günstig ist, sind die hier. Die sind echt günstig, aber das
ist so eine Seite, wo ich denke, ich weiß nicht. Ich weiß aber auch nicht, ob die DE Domains
zu Cloudflare umziehen. Wie? Cackle.de ist unavailable. Omega Cackle, ist das vielleicht?
Okay, 5,55 Euro im Jahr. Und Renews at 4 Dollar. Na gut. Ich weiß nicht, ich habe gerade versucht
über Cloudflare.de zu registrieren. Das hat nicht funktioniert. Was aber eigentlich nicht
sein kann? Was mir nicht wirklich einleuchtet. Omega Cackle.de, sagt er mir bei Cloudflare,
does not have a supported Toplevel Domain. Also aus irgendwelchen Gründen kann Cloudflare
keine DE Domains. Das wäre aber äußerst weird champ. Ich kann euch sagen, warum ich
gerne Cloudflare für Domains verwende und für DNS. Weil die überall eingebaut sind
als supporteter Service. Sei es Thirdport, sei es Cuddy, sei es Trafix, egal was. Der
Hetzer DNS hat zwar mittlerweile auch eine API, aber die ist nicht so weit verbreitet
als Plugin. Und ich bin mir nicht sicher, wie Hetzer mit Fake-Daten umgeht. Cloudflare
ist es egal. Ja bei Cloudflare heiße ich Peter Agil Wuppel oder so und wohne in Frankfurt
in der Kappa Street. Das interessieren die nicht. Das ist denen vollkommen egal. Alles
klar so. Und die machen echt keine DE. Das wundert mich ja. Das ist natürlich schon
mal doof. Weil eigentlich, ich habe eine DE Domain, nämlich maxfps.de und die wollte
ich eigentlich. Gibt es da noch einen oder was? Was ist hier los? Geht nicht. Kürzlich
hinzugefügte demnächst verfügbare.de. Ne, das sind die, die sie nicht, die sie unterstützt.
Warum? Warum macht Cloudflare keine DE Domains? Was ist das? Das ist doch Pepega Shit oder?
Das ist tatsächlich interessant, das hätte ich nicht gedacht. Tja.
Ja, keine Ahnung warum die kein DE, AT und sowas haben. Also ich habe meine, ich würde
meine Domains theoretisch auch zu Hetzer umziehen. Kein Problem. Aber meine ganzen Domains
haben irgendwelche. Das einzige was bei meinen Domains stimmt ist die E-Mail Adresse. Der
Rest ist Fake-Owner, Fake-Daten. Ich sehe überhaupt nicht einen da, meine echten Daten
einzutragen. Und ich glaube, Hetzer kontrolliert, ob das stimmt oder zumindest ob es irgendwie
plausibel ist. Zweifelsfall auch sowas wie mit Ausweis-Scan und sowas. Ich meine, ich
mache mit meinen Domains nichts Schlimmes, aber ich will trotzdem keine echten Daten
eintragen. Da wohne ich lieber in der Cackle-Street 123. Mir doch egal. Okay, so und zwar was
ich mir jetzt überlegt habe. Folgendes machen wir heute. Ich will, wie gesagt, ich will
alle meine Domains umziehen zu Cloudflare. Schreibe ich, was habe ich da reingeschrieben
das letzte Mal? Was habe ich da in meinem Preis-Champ ins Impressum geschrieben? Ich
habe das Impressum verlinkt auf meinen YouTube-Channel. So hatte ich das gemacht. Nee, muss nicht,
das muss eine Anschrift enthalten, wo man mich im Zweifelsfall vorladen kann oder so.
Und das macht's ja. Deswegen, ich mache einfach keine deutschen Webseiten mehr. Fertig. Brauche
ich kein Impressum. Es ist teilweise echt lächerlich. Aber gut, was willst du machen?
Zumindest, nachdem ich vorhabe, alle meine Domains auf Cloudflare umzuziehen. Doch, doch,
doch, doch, schon, schon, das geht auch. Aber dann musst du bei drei verschiedenen Anbietern
oder vier verschiedenen Anbietern nachgucken, ob deine Domain expiren. Also, ich habe vor
meine Domains umzuziehen zu Cloudflare alle. Vielen Dank für den Sub und danke schön
an... Die Abo-Falle hat zugeschlagen. Nice. Ja, die Abo-Falle ist ziemlich... Prime-Pork
ist sie. Und mir ist aufgefallen, dass ich es letztens erst ganz knapp noch mitbekommen
habe, dass eine meiner Domains abgelaufen wäre. Und deswegen habe ich mir gedacht,
ich sollte das mal in mein Monitoring aufnehmen, dass meine Domains ordentlich überwacht werden.
Das heißt, was ich heute mal probieren werde, ist folgendes. Und zwar, ich habe mir über
die Cloudflare API rausgesucht, wie man Domains abfragen kann. Oh, jetzt laggt da Stream. Stream
laggen. Also, ich habe mir über die Cloudflare API rausgesucht, wie man Domains abfragen
kann bzw. Domain Registration abfragen kann von seinen eigenen Domains. Weil es ist halt
so, wenn man Whois macht, das habe ich eben gerade gezeigt, wenn man Whois, also WhoismaxFPS.de,
der Denig rückt keine Expire-Dates raus. Wohingegen Cloudflare über die API das natürlich
macht. Was ziemlich doof ist, ehrlich gesagt, dass Cloudflare keine DE-Domains unterstützt.
Da muss ich mir überlegen, wie ich das mache. Vielleicht kriege ich das doch anderweitig
raus. Aber es hat für den Stream heute keine Auswirkungen. Wir probieren das trotzdem.
Und zwar, ich habe mir rausgesucht über Cloudflare, wie man über die API was ausliest. Und was
wir jetzt mal probieren ist, Repos Kekkel Trust. Was wir jetzt mal probieren ist folgendes.
Wir basteln jetzt ein kleines Programm, was über die Cloudflare API die Domain Registration
abfragt. Und dann, wenn wir das haben, bauen wir einen Prometheus Note-Exporter daraus
und wir machen die an Output so, dass ein Zappix den verarbeiten kann. Weil es ist bei
mir lokal so, ich habe fürs Monitoring lokal ein Zappix am Start, aber ihr kennt mich,
ich bin da immer so ein bisschen hin und her gerissen. Ich bin auch mit der Zappix-Geschichte
nicht wirklich glücklich. Und vielleicht mache ich auch wieder mein Grafana und Prometheus
Zeug an. Mal gucken, zumindest will ich beides unterstützen, dass ich mit beiden Monitoring-Systemen
die Gültigkeit meiner Domain abfragen kann. Es gibt auf GitHub einige Projekte, die genau
so was machen, aber die funktionieren alle nicht, weil die alle auf WhoIs-Abfragen zurückgreifen.
Das ist tatsächlich das Schlimme. Zappix ist noch für so klassisches Monitoring mit
das Erträglichste und Zappix sagt auch. Ist ja der Witz. Wobei ich sagen muss, prinzipiell
vom Ansatz her finde ich sowohl Zappix als auch Grafana Prometheus eigentlich ziemlich
gut. Es hat halt unterschiedliche Stärken. Alles was dynamisch ist, ist in Zappix ziemlicher
Pains-Champ und in Prometheus ganz okay durch dieses ganze Gelabler und so. Aber umgedreht,
so klassische Sachen wie ich habe hier 5 Hosts, will die anping ohne Nachricht haben, wenn
der Ping nicht mehr geht. Man glaubt das vielleicht gar nicht, aber das ist mit Prometheus Grafana
gar nicht mal so easy. Geht auch. Ja, Jack-MK ist doch immer noch Nagios unter der Haube,
oder? Es ist teilweise schlimm. Jedes Sacken die meisten Monitoring-Tools. Ich kann es
auch nicht ganz nachvollziehen, warum das alles so Pains-Champig sein muss. Abtime-Kuma finde
ich tatsächlich ganz cool für daheim, das hat mir aber dann doch ein wenig zu wenig
Features für das, was ich gerne machen möchte. Also aktuell bin ich bei Zappix hängen geblieben
und so werde ich es wahrscheinlich auch erstmal lassen. Also Leute, ich habe ein Konsolenprogramm
gebastelt und zwar, was über die Cloudflare API abfragt, was ich für Domains habe. Ihr
seht hier vielleicht, ich habe da ganz viele Secrets drin stehen, die ich nicht will, dass
der Stream das sieht. Deswegen habe ich hier eine Klasse, die sich QtChatGibated nennt und
da stehen meine ganzen Secrets drin, verschlüsselt in dieser Datei. Also ich habe hier eine Datei,
da steht alles verschlüsselt drin und hier in der QtChat-Klasse habe ich die Passwörter
drin, um das zu entschlüsseln, dass wenn ich aus Versehen da drauf klicke oder da drauf
klicke, dass ihr da nichts damit anfangen könnt und nicht zufälligerweise den API-Key
für meinen Cloudflare-Account habt. Da bin ich nämlich nicht so scharf drauf und für
den Fall der Fälle, dass ich doch beides liegen sollte, habe ich hier noch Cloudflare auf
dem zweiten Monitor auf und kann einfach das API revulken. Ich habe extra ein Git Ignore
drin, wo das Secrets-File mit dabei ist. Nein ich vertraue euch nicht, so weit vertraue ich
euch nicht. Ich zeige keine AP Secrets hier im Klartext. Mir ist noch keine bessere Lösung
eingefallen, wie ich sowas im Stream absichern kann. Wisst ihr was ich persönlich gerne hätte,
aber sowas habe ich noch nicht gefunden. Ich hätte gerne einen generellen Konsolen-Output-Filter,
wo ich ein paar Sachen hinterlegen kann und der jeglichen Output der Konsole durchscant
und guckt ob das da drin steht und dann rauslöscht. Das stimmt, die Klasse ist nicht drin, aber
das Secrets-File, ihr könnt halt nichts anfangen mit dem einen noch mit dem anderen. Ja, du
meinst den Haschikorb Vault, das ist aber doch über, da habe ich mir letztens ein Tutorial
zu angeguckt. Das ist aber doch über HTTP. Das bringt mir jetzt da nicht so wirklich viel.
Was nimmst du? Was? Doppler Secrets? Das kenne ich nicht. Das ist irgendein Webservice für
mein... Ne, also in der Cloud will ich meine Secrets eigentlich jetzt nicht speichern.
Doch, das würde theoretisch funktionieren, aber ich habe halt gehofft, dass jemand sowas
schon gebaut hat, was dann auch schnell ist. So irgendein Output-Filter in Rust oder so,
dass die ganzen Rust-Hackermans vielleicht sowas schon gebaut haben. Das wäre nicht
schlecht. Es müsste eigentlich ja ein T-Max-Aufsatz oder ein kompletter Terminal-Aufsatz sein,
dass du nicht jedes Command durchpipen musst. Ich habe auch noch was in Environment-Variablen
stehen, also selbst wenn ich beides leake, bringt euch das trotzdem nichts. Aber das
könnte ja auch sein, dass ich das leake. Deswegen habe ich das jetzt alles rausgelassen.
Ja, und auch in Environment-Variablen ist so ein Ding. Im Zweifelsfall gehe ich in der
History hoch und sowas. Man weiß es nicht. Kann ja alles sein. Oder ich habe irgendwas
in... Muss übrigens mein... Passwort-Manager wieder starten. Der ist immer noch kaputt.
Jetzt geht er wieder, alles klar. So, also ich zeige euch mal, was ich schon gebaut habe.
Ihr seht, das ist relativ unspektakulär. Also wir gehen jetzt mal rein. CD, Cackle,
.NET, Run und dann kommt folgende Ausgabe. Ja, das muss ich mir mal angucken. Wahrscheinlich
ist das am besten, wenn ich das in irgendeinem Vault-Lokal packe. Ah ja, ok, das war einfach
nur langsam die Ausgabe. Also, folgenden Output kriege ich hier gerade von der Cloudflare
API. Boah, die ist aber gerade mega langsam. Also folgenden Output haben wir hier. Domainskappa0.com,
die habe ich extra für euch registriert, Leute, damit wir Domains haben zum ausprobieren.
Ich habe 2x7 Euro ausgegeben, 2x7 Dollar ausgegeben, nur für euch, nur für den Stream, damit wir
das jetzt mal ausprobieren können. Weil die normalen Domains und die Accounts für den
Stream will ich nicht unbedingt alles immer über einen Haufen werfen, weil sonst leak
ich hier doch noch mal in irgendwas, was ich nicht leaken will. Also folgende Domains gibt
es gerade in diesem Cloudflare-Account. Kappa0.com. Kappa0.com ist expired am 10.07.2023. Kalle
Flash für den Zapp. Und als zweite Domain haben wir hier noch, ah, irgendwelches Blabla,
was kein Mensch braucht. Und als zweite Domain haben wir noch omega-kekel.com. Ihr seht,
mir sind die Ideen für die Domains ausgegangen. Ich habe einfach Forms, nee, nicht Formstream,
das war gestern sogar schon. Sieht man ja hier, Contacts Updated und so. Ich habe die Domains
gestern schon random mal gekauft, weil ich mir gedacht habe, man könnte mal einen Stream
drüber machen. Also kappa0.com und omega-kekel.com haben wir als Domain. Beste. Klingt nach, ja,
ich würde sagen neue Startup-Domains. Guck mal, da sieht man sogar, was es kostet aktuell.
Registration Fee 8 Dollar 39. Keine Kosten und Mühen, so sieht es aus. Also ich habe
2 mal 8 Euro 39 bezahlt, so wie es aussieht. Also 17 Euro ungefähr. Das ist 8 Euro, ist
für eine Comdomain gar nicht mal so teuer. Dollar, Dollar, nicht Euro, nicht Euro, Dollar.
Das ist durchaus okay, viel billig. Was würde es denn zum Beispiel woanders kosten? Nimmt
sich wahrscheinlich gar nicht viel. Die E-Domains sind halt billig. Kann man doch mal gucken
hier. Was will er zum Beispiel Namecheap dafür? Ja, omega-coggers.com. Ja, kostet genau das
gleiche. tldlist.com. Okay, gucken wir mal. omega-coggers.com. Also 8 Euro 55. Also 8
Euro. Moment, Moment, Moment, was ist das für eine Domain? Also es kostet alles 8
Euro in dem Dreh. Hier kostet es halt 8,55. Das erste Jahr ist wahrscheinlich so. Viel
günstiger als bei Cloudflare ist das andere Zeug auch nicht. Ist aber auch wurscht. Also
das ist die Output, die ich von der Cloudflare AP kriege. Und jetzt muss ich da draus irgendwas
bauen, was Zabbix und Prometheus schluckt. Prometheus, wir machen beides. Wir machen
einfach Kommandozeile. Wenn ich das Ding starte mit "--zabbix", kommt der Zabbix Output.
Wenn ich das starte mit "--exporter", dann wird es halt Prometheus Zeug exportieren.
Spooky Musik wieder hier. Skippen. Angst. Ja, aber ganz bestimmt nicht die.com Domain.
Ach, aber 8 pro Monat. Da sind wir doch sogar bei mehr im Jahr. Das hier sind ja alles Preise
im Jahr, was ich euch gezeigt habe, nicht im Monat. Das sind ja alles, Leute, das sind
alles Jahrespreise hier. 8 Dollar im Jahr, nicht habe ich im Monat gesagt. Im Jahr. Im
Jahr. So, also. Ach ja, und wenn wir das dann gemacht haben, wenn wir das Tool gebaut haben,
was Grafana und Zabbix Zeug exportieren kann, dann mache ich den Raspberry Pi an und wir
hauen das dort auf den Zabbix drauf und im Prometheus Grafana mache ich lokal im Docker
Container schnell, dass wir es ausprobieren können. Wie wahrscheinlich ist es, dass es
bald in Deutschland das komplette Internet lahmlegt? Sehr unwahrscheinlich. Wie kommst
du da drauf? Könnte sowas passieren wie in Kanada? Wie sowas ist denn in Kanada passiert?
Da habe ich nichts mitgekriegt von. Was ist in Kanada passiert? Baum gefällt, Leitung
zerstört, Biber legt Internet und Mobilfunk in Norden, Kanada. Tja, nee, sowas wird hier
wahrscheinlich nicht passieren, gehe ich nicht davon aus. Der Biber hat in Single
Point of Failure gefunden, wie es aussieht. Das kann bei uns aber in der Form nicht passieren.
Dafür haben wir andere Probleme mit unserem Internet. Okay, also auf geht's. Wir machen
jetzt, wir machen jetzt, wie gesagt, Konsolen Ausgabe für Konsolen Anwendung für was was
was Zabbix Format unterstützt und was Prometheus Format und Format unterstützt und ich bin
mir gar nicht mehr sicher. Ich glaube Prometheus.net oder so hieß der Kram, um Nodexporter machen
zu können in Dotnet. Was ist Dotnet Metas? Was? Keine Ahnung. So, also was wir in der
Ausgabe hier drin haben, von dem Jason sieht man ja, was uns interessiert ist eigentlich
nur bei Results, die Domains und Expire. Also wir machen folgende Ausgabe, Domain, Expire
Date und irgendwie Time Left oder irgendwie sowas. Würde ich sagen, machen wir das als
Output. Das ist glaube ich relativ sinnvoll. Okay, so, also das wollen wir als Jason haben.
Warte mal, wie ist der Campbell formatiert? Es gibt ein Objekt und darin ist ein Result
Key und in diesem Result Key ist dann ein Array drinne mit. Okay, machen wir mal Dynamic.
Mal schauen. So, Url. Wie heißt das? Result? Result. So, wenn ich das jetzt richtig gemacht
habe, ich will ja, dass ihr was seht, deswegen mache ich das Terminal hier unten. Repos,
beste, beste Namen überhaupt.net. Run. So, wenn das jetzt funktioniert. Ja, es funktioniert,
da sind die Results drinne. So, und von den Results, da ist ein Array drinne und da jeweils
die Domains. Okay, also müsste ich sowas hier machen können. Mal testen, ob das funktioniert.
For each, Domain, in Result, Domain, Punkt und dann Name. So, jetzt sollte ich eine Liste
raus bekommen mit den beiden Domains, wenn das funktioniert. Und da ist es, kappa0 omega
keckel, alles klar. Beste Domainnamen aller Zeiten. Gut, also die Domainnamen aber raus,
dann brauchen wir jetzt noch das Expire Date. Seht ihr das? Wo steht es denn? Eben habe
ich es gefunden. Wo ist das Expire Date? Ach hier, da, nee, payment expires, ach da, expires
add. Okay, da ist, also sprich, was ist denn das für ein Format? Ist das, ist das dieses,
wie heißt das dieses Standard ISO, ISO 9000, nee, fragt mich nicht, ISO irgendwas, Date,
ja ISO, genau, ISO 8601, das klingt, das klingt gut Leute. Irgendwas, irgendwas mit ISO. Es
ist auf jeden Fall UTC, ja. Okay, expires add, haben wir noch zu bieten, Domain, expires add.
Das ist wirklich, das ist glaube ich dir, ISO 8601, ist ein internationaler Standard
der ISO, der Empfehlung über das numerische Datumsformat und Zeitangaben enthält, alles
klar. Guck, so sieht dann, so sieht dann ein ISO, ISO 8601. Jetzt habe ich wieder was gelernt.
Wenn ich mir nicht merken kann bis zum nächsten Mal, mir reicht es schon, dass ich mir die
WLAN Sachen merken kann mit 802.11ax und 800, Moment, was ist nochmal WLAN, 802.11.Q, war
das WLAN? Nicht WLAN, WLAN, WLAN meine ich, Punkt Q, Q hinten dran, 802.11Q, ja WLAN Technik,
genau. Allein schon, es ist schon nicht normal, dass man sich das überhaupt merkt, sowas.
So, jetzt haben wir die Domain, jetzt haben wir die, das expire date. Okay. Da blickste,
da blickste echt einmal durch. Also bei WLAN blickste nicht durch, WLAN ist der Standard,
er ändert sich halt nicht viel. Ich weiß gar nicht, Wi-Fi 6 ist ja, Wi-Fi 6 ist 802.11ax,
ach das war ax schon, ja genau. Ich muss sagen, die WLAN Standard Leute machen es ganz gut,
weil Wi-Fi 6 ist doch deutlich griffiger als IEEE 802.11ax. Wenn du irgendeinem Noob sagst,
ja sie haben einen IEEE 802.11ax Router, dann denkt er, was willst du von mir, wenn du ihm
sagst Wi-Fi 6, dann ist, wobei die auch ein bisschen verkackt haben, und jetzt sind wir
bei Wi-Fi 6e. Das ist auch ein bisschen wir jetzt, ja. Na gut, also wir haben die Domain-Name,
so, expire. So, wie ging das jetzt noch einmal, from date time offset, from Unix time oder sowas.
Ne, Moment. From? Oder war das so, war das date pass? Pass? Wir sind nicht in JavaScript.
Pass exakt. Okay, was ist der Unterschied? Was ist der Unterschied zwischen date time und einem
date time offset? Ich wusste das mal, aber ich habe das so selten verwendet. So, wir müssen uns
das mal anmelden. Der date time offset bietet die, auch Microsoft deutsche Übersetzung, please.
Gibt es das, ich will das auf Englisch haben. Hier, ne, warte mal, der Knopf. Ja, okay, also.
Also erklär mal, erklär mal. Date time offset structure represents date and time value together
with offset. From UTC, wir haben es ja in UTC. Meine Güte. Okay, also true string. Ach nee,
das bringt ja nichts. Das ist ja weiter dynamic. Wir müssen es glaube ich casten zu stringen,
wie das funktioniert. Wait. Ach, da muss man das Format angeben. Könnte ich einfach so pass machen?
Mal gucken, ob er das checkt oder abkackt. Das scheint zu funktionieren. Expire. Okay,
er checkt. Also, passt. 12.52 UTC. Alles klar. Okay, gut. Ist richtig so. So, den Name können wir
auch. Das ist übrigens echt verwirrend. Wenn du hier sagst to string, ist es witzigerweise hier
vorne kein String, sondern du musst das, du musst das casten dazu. Weil dynamic shit. Okay,
von uns, also wir haben das Name, wir haben das Expire. Und dann sind wir mal. Heißt das
Expiration? Gibt es das Wort Ablauf? Okay. Date. Nennen wir es so. Gut. Weil dann haben wir noch
time left oder so. Weiß ich genau, wie ich das nennen soll. Da rechnen wir jetzt aus,
wie viel Zeit ist noch übrig? Also sprich, also hier haben wir das Datum, wann die Domain
abläuft. Und jetzt will ich noch wissen, also sprich, wie lang ist es denn noch hin zu dem Datum?
Nee. To string gibt immer die jeweilige String representation von dem Objekt aus. Das kannst du,
das kann es, es würde mich übrigens auch wundern, wenn das in Java so wäre. Das kannst du aber auch
ändern. Ich zeige euch mal was cooles. Was ist jetzt ein neues Feature? Hältst du die Grenzen?
Halbwegs, halbwegs neues Feature. Guckt mal, wenn ihr eine Klasse macht, die Kekkelklasse,
ja, und da habt ihr dann irgendwelche Felder drinstehen. Ja, so was wie hier.
Aja ja ist gleich Sebaro oder so, keine Ahnung. Wenn da so was drinsteht und ihr legt jetzt die
Klasse an und sagt, ihr müsst nicht to string machen, weil ConsoleWriteLine das eigentlich
selbst macht, aber ich zeige es euch trotzdem mal, dass es hier explizit klar ist. Dann kommt
als Antwort beziehungsweise hier als Output kommt an der Stelle bloß Kekkelklasse. Warum? Weil die
Standard to string Methode immer den Klasse Namen nimmt dafür. So was man jetzt machen kann ist,
aber das ist gar nicht die schönste Variante mittlerweile. Was man machen kann ist override
to string und da könnte man jetzt zum Beispiel Custom Sachen returnen. Man könnte zum Beispiel
sagen, ach nee, ich will in der Ausgabe tatsächlich drinstehen haben cute chat Dings Sebaro oder so.
Und wenn ich das jetzt mache, dann kommt bei to string halt das überschriebene raus. Aber es gibt
ein neues, neu ist das Feature nicht, das gibt es auch seit 2 Jahren oder 3 Jahren schon, aber ich
zeige es euch trotzdem mal, weil das relativ oft vorkommt, man das gar nicht im Hinterkopf hat,
wenn man es braucht. Was? Aber beim, ja genau, das will ich jetzt auch zeigen. Es kommt ja oftmals
vor, dass man solche, dass man solche, du quältst dich mit der Arbeit mit ASP.NET Core, ich mag
ASP.NET Core. Es kommt ja vor, dass man, dass man solche Klassen hat hier zum Beispiel, wo einfach
nur irgendwelche Felder gesetzt werden und gar nichts großartiges drin ist. So, was weiß ich,
string, Pong ist keckwee, ist vollkommen egal was da drinsteht. Man hat so Klassen und wenn man
die jetzt standardmäßig ausgeben will, by the way das to string hier, wie gesagt, braucht man
nicht, kann man weglassen und dann funktioniert das. Dann gibt das halt nix Sinnvolles aus und wenn
ihr aber einfach aus dieser Klasse ein Rekord macht und sonst nix ändert und den ausgibt,
dann kriegt ihr als Output ein schön formatiertes Struct oder halt ein schön formatiertes
Output von der Klasse. Also ihr müsst einfach nur ein Rekord draus machen, man muss aber wissen,
da kommt noch ein bisschen mehr mit. Also man sollte nicht einfach sinnlos Klassen zu Rekords
machen umgedreht, weil zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt checken will, machen wir mal eine Sache.
Was kommt hier jetzt raus? Was kommt in dieser Ausgabe jetzt raus? Also ich mach ne neue Klasse
und guck ob die gleich, ich leg ne neue Instanz der Klasse an und zweimal neue Instanz und guck ob
die gleich, was kommt da raus? Da kommt Falls raus, richtig. So, das ist übrigens so lahm,
weil ich jedes mal die Cloudflare ab hier oben drüber noch abfrag. Falls. Und jetzt mach ich
den Rekord raus und was passiert jetzt? Was kommt jetzt raus? Ich mein die Frage ist relativ
offensichtlich, weil wenn jetzt Falls rauskommt und ich frag so blöd, dann kommt jetzt True raus.
Und dann fragt man sich, warum? Tja, weil das ist kein Struct oder sowas. Könnte man jetzt
vielleicht denken. Rekords sind Data Classes, genau. Rekords überschreibt standardmäßig to
String und Equals und Zeugs. Die schönere Variante wäre es so zu schreiben, dass man
etwas genauer erkennt was das eigentlich ist. Das ist aber auch erst seit der letzten C-Sharp
Version möglich das so zu schreiben, weil sie auf die glorreiche Idee gekommen sind,
haben sich gedacht, also wenn wir jetzt Klassen ein bisschen so wie Structs machen, warum machen
wir da nicht auch Structs zu Structs? Deswegen gibt es seit der letzten C-Sharp Version auch
noch Rekords Struct. Nee, ich weiß aber nicht, wie man das schreibt. Doch, das ist richtig so.
Ach so, ich muss einen Constructor machen. Das funktioniert. Benutzt man äußerst selten.
Ich habe Rekords Structs noch nie verwendet. Ist auch so ähnlich bei Java. Ja, das ist,
hab noch nicht ganz verstanden, weshalb. Also, guck mal, das ist eigentlich relativ, relativ klar
und das ist in mehr oder weniger jeder halbwegs objektorientierten Sprache. Also legen wir mal
eine Variante an. Das ist Cackle 1 und das ist 2. Und jetzt machen wir hier nochmal, ich mach
mal kurz die Cloudflare ab hier oben drüber weg. Es braucht nämlich ein bisschen lang,
bis das immer ausgefüllt wird. Das hier. So. Hallo? Wir machen mal was Simples. 1, 1. Und jetzt frage
ich mal raus, ist das gleich, gleich das? Also das ist der simpelste Fall überhaupt. Also sprich,
ist 1, gleich, gleich 1. Und ist 1, gleich 1. Da erwartet jetzt ja an der Stelle jeder,
dass True rauskommt. Außer vielleicht den Javascript, da wäre ich mir bei solchen
Vergleichen prinzipiell nie sicher, ob da True, False, Not a Number, Undefined, Null oder irgendwas
anderes rauskommt. Aber in den normalen Programmiersprachen würde man in der Regel
davon ausgehen, ja, da kommt überall eigentlich True raus. Jetzt kommt der Unterschied an der
ganzen Geschichte. Wenn du jetzt nicht, ich glaube bei Java nennt sich das Build in Types,
bin ich mir gar nicht sicher, wie sich das nennt bei Java, ich hab nicht so Ahnung davon. So. Also
hier können wir uns aber glaube ich darauf einigen, dass das hier ein Wert ist. Primitives in Java kann
sein. Also das hier ist ein Wert. Das ist quasi ein Value-Type, könnte man sagen. Das ist ein Wert. So.
Und der Wert ist quasi für sich selbst genommen schon der, äh, wie soll man das, wie nennt man
das richtig? Die Identität? Ne, weiß jetzt gar nicht, wie man das richtig nennt. Aber der Wert
steht für sich alleine. Ja, also ein Wert gleich gleich einem anderen Wert ist immer True, wenn der
Wert gleich ist. So. Der Unterschied ist jetzt, wenn ich jetzt eine Klasse anlege und keinen Wert,
dann ist das hier nicht mehr der Wert, sondern das ist eigentlich nur ein Verweis auf diese Klasse.
Also sprich, in der Klasse wird definiert, was ist denn für, ähm, Properties, Werte und was
du für Felder hast. Und hier legst du quasi eine Instanz der Klasse an. Also sprich, das hier ist
jetzt quasi ein Zeiger, wenn du es so willst. Eine Referenz auf die Stelle, war ganz abstrakt gesagt,
oder eine, eine Referenz auf die Stelle im Arbeitsspeicher. In C++ wäre es übrigens direkt so,
ähm, oder in C. Im Arbeitsspeicher, wo jetzt diese, wo diese Klasse instanziert wurde. Deswegen kannst
du ja auch sowas hier machen. Punkt H gleich 1, 2, H gleich 2. Und das ist nicht immer exakt das
gleiche. Das sind 2 komplett unterschiedlich voneinander agierende Instanzen von der Kackelklasse.
Also sprich, das ist eine Referenz und das hier ist ein Wert. Deswegen ist das ein ReferenceType
und das andere ist ein ValueType. ValueTypes, wenn der Value gleich ist, ist diese Bedingung
auch gleich. ReferenceTypes vergleicht der nicht, ist das die gleiche Klasse, sondern der guckt,
ist das die gleiche Adresse, worauf die zeigen. Hier, das ist aber kein ValueType. Also sprich,
der vergleicht quasi die Adressen von den beiden Dingern und stellt fest, das ist nicht gleich.
Das kannst du relativ einfach feststellen, indem du sagst, ok Adrun, da kommt jetzt Falls raus.
Wenn du allerdings jetzt sagst, Kackel 2 gleich Kackel 1, dann kommt da True raus. Weil jetzt
zeigt 2 auf die gleiche Adresse, wo 1 drauf zeigt. Also hier checkt er die Referenz bzw.
denkst du einfach als Speicheradresse. D.h. 2 Instanzen sind nie gleich. Es sei denn,
es ist die gleiche Instanz. D.h. was du damit checkst, ist nicht, ob der Wert gleich ist.
Also checkst du ja auch nicht, ob die Werte innen drinne irgendwie gleich sind, sondern
du checkst wirklich, zeig das auf die gleiche Klasse, also auf die gleiche Instanz, auf
den gleichen Speicherbereich. Deswegen ist das anders. Warum funktioniert das so? Also
sprich, warum ist das jetzt True? Naja, weil Record unter der Haube etwas Compiler Magic
macht und so Sachen wie Equals überschreibt. Also du kannst auch, das macht man normalerweise
nicht, weil das äußerst verwirrend ist, also du kannst dieses Verhalten auch überschreiben.
Du kannst z.B. Equals überschreiben und da kannst du dann sagen, ja nö, das ist doch
gleich wenn die Werte gleich sind oder so. Das funktioniert. Das macht man normalerweise
nicht, weil man eben erwartet, dass es bei einer Klasse um die Referenz geht und nicht
um den Inhalt. Wenn du jetzt ein Struct verwendest, was sich anders verhält, was dann eher einem
Value entspricht, dann würde das wieder funktionieren, aber ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, Structs
verwendet man in der Tat ziemlich selten und seit es Records gibt, habe ich Structs gar
nicht mehr verwendet. Also ein Record ist quasi eine Klasse, die für dich schon nur
String überschrieben hat und die Equals überschrieben hat und die glaube ich auch den Operator
überladen hat. Das macht Record für dich, aber halt sinnvoll, nicht Return Base, sondern
mit was sinnvollem drin. Dann funktioniert das. So die Basics haben wir jetzt wieder gemacht.
Ich glaube Point ist ein Struct. Können wir mal gucken. Point ist ein Struct, genau.
Ja das kann ich jetzt an der Stelle auch nochmal kurz zeigen. So, können wir uns nochmal angucken.
Wenn ich jetzt sage New Point, wohlgemerkt Point ist ein Struct, keine Klasse. Wenn ich
sage New Point und zum Beispiel Point 0 und 1 und hier Point keine Ahnung 0 und 2, dann
ist das False. Warum? Weil die Werte unterschiedlich sind. Sobald ich jetzt hier auch eine 1 reinschreibe,
dass die Werte gleich sind, dann ist das auch True. Weil das ein Struct ist und keine Klasse
ist. Aber ganz im Ernst, Structs verwendet man ziemlich selten. Spätestens jetzt seitens
Records gibt. Also kann man eine Variable mit einem Objekt mit einem Record vergleichen
oder kann man nur Record und Record vergleichen? Das ist eine gute Frage. Das weiß ich gar
nicht. Ob der dann meckert? Ich gehe mal davon aus, das wird funktionieren, aber mal ausprobieren.
Guck mal mal. Also du kannst höchstwahrscheinlich Struct und Klasse nicht miteinander vergleichen.
Weiß ich jetzt gar nicht. Aber New Point? Ok, das funktioniert schon mal nicht. Du kannst
kein Struct, du kannst kein Point und Klasse miteinander vergleichen. Wo ich mir jetzt
aber nicht sicher bin ist, wenn ich hier ein Record raus mache, was dann passiert? Das
geht auch nicht. Das geht auch nicht. Ich kann nicht Kekkelklasse und Kekkelklasse Record
vergleichen. Wobei das funktioniert so natürlich auch nicht. Das hat mit Record jetzt gar nichts
zu tun. Das funktioniert so auch nicht, weil es unterschiedliche Typen sind. Da ist er
schon schlau genug, dass es nicht funktioniert. Das heißt das Problem hast du gar nicht.
Das Problem hast du höchstens wenn du beides zu Object castest. Dann bin ich mal gespannt
was da passiert jetzt. Ich hab keine Ahnung ehrlich gesagt. Was kommt da jetzt raus?
Falls. Ok, weil die Referenz mit Kekkel 1 ist ja auch hier zu. Und wenn ich das umgedreht
mache. Das sind ja noch beides. Ok, da ist er schlau genug. Das sind aber so Dinger,
das sollte man eher nicht machen, weil da blickt dann keiner mehr genau durch was du
eigentlich vor hattest. Ja kann schon sein. Bekommen Lion. Dankeschön für den Sub. Also
man kann es natürlich auch kompliziert machen. Zumindest kommen wir mal zurück zur eigentlichen
Geschichte, die ich machen will. Nämlich meine Cloudflare Domain Expiration abfragen.
Wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben? Genau, also ich bekomme jetzt das Datum. Wo ich jetzt
muss ich mir jetzt mal angucken. Was ist denn jetzt der Unterschied zwischen dem und, keine
Ahnung, 2? Mir fällt gerade nichts besseres ein. Was ist jetzt der Unterschied zwischen
dem und DatetimeOffSetPass? Aha, das hier denkt es ist in meiner Zeit und das andere
denkt es ist in UTC. Das heißt ich müsste dem eigentlich da noch bei, das Offset kann
ich dem noch sagen, was das für ein Offset hat? CultureInfo? Das ist relativ neu. Ach
hier kann ich das Offset setzen. Achso hier kann ich quasi die Zeitzonen dann, wenn ich
das, das ist aber eklig, aber ich verstehe es glaube ich jetzt. Okay, ja ich meine wir
brauchen es ja nur in UTC. So also ich habe den Name von der Domain und ich habe die Zeit
wann die Domain abläuft. Und jetzt brauche ich noch TimeLeft oder so, also sprich TimeLeft
in, ja in UnixTime würde ich sagen, UnixTimeBeste. Da bin ich nämlich mal gespannt wie man das
jetzt hinbekommt, also. Okay, also kann ich jetzt sagen Datetime, das kann ich sagen DateTimeNow?
Nee, Schwachsinn umgedreht. Xperience minus DateTimeNow. Geht das nicht? Ach Quatsch,
das ist keine Methode, das ist einfach nur so. So und jetzt kriege ich angezeigt, wie
viel, es ist noch nicht in UnixTime. Stimmt, ich müsste NowUTC verwenden, weil der mein
Lokales nimmt, ja genau. Okay das heißt wir haben noch DaysLeft bis das Zertifikat, äh
nicht Zertifikat, bis die Domain abläuft. 363 und 364 Tage, das passt, ich habe die
jetzt nämlich gestern registriert. Ja okay, das leuchtet ein und ja und jetzt passt natürlich
auch, es ist auch sinnvoll, das da oben DateTimeOffset zu verwenden. So, das heißt, wenn ich
das jetzt wissen will in UnixTime, wie, oh fuck, wie kriege ich das jetzt in UnixTime,
das geht doch irgendwie, DateTimeOffset. Ach nee, Moment, das ist, nee Moment, das ist
eine TimeSpan. Ah, ah, Hilfe, Datumszeugskonvertierungskram, ah, please, okay, ganz, ganz langsam, also,
ich habe jetzt eine TimeSpan, da steht bla bla bla Tage drin, das macht ja keinen Sinn
in UnixTime. Das macht generell keinen Sinn in UnixTime. TimeLeft in UnixTime macht überhaupt
keinen Sinn. Wollte ich gerade sagen, das macht eigentlich überhaupt keinen Sinn. So
ist es eigentlich Sinn, es reicht ja schon. Es ist eigentlich vollkommen, vollkommen okay.
So, und sowas in Sekunden wäre dann quasi noch, ach nee, total seconds. Okay, das ergibt
mehr Sinn, alles klar. Was TwoSeconds kann man auch machen, wirklich, nee, total seconds,
richtig. Also, es sind noch, ähm, 31.465.331 Sekunden. Alles klar, easy, da weiß man Bescheid.
Gut, jetzt haben wir alles, was man braucht und jetzt muss ich das irgendwie als Jason
formatieren. Also, sprich, einmal die Zabbix-Ausgabe und dann die Prometheus-Ausgabe. Zabbix-Ausgabe
wird relativ einfach sein. Warte mal, Zabbix? Zabbix? Wie muss der Krempel nochmal aussehen
bei Zabbix? Es muss irgendwie ein Jason-Array sein oder so. Das ist auch ein Punkt, den
ich bei Zabbix eklig finde, die Config. Das ist einfach massive hängen geblieben, Alter,
für dynamische Sachen. What the f... Ah ja, hier steht es doch, wie das aussehen muss.
Okay, Array und dann die ganzen Sachen drinnen. Also. Machen wir das doch mal ein bisschen
moderner. Select, ähm, Domain, zack, zack, return, new. Vielleicht mach ich das jetzt
auch. Wobei, das kann man bestimmt noch, noch schöner machen. Time left. Was ist das jetzt
für Schmerzen? Alter, geht das nicht mit Dynamic? Oder muss ich da, hä? Muss ich
Dynamic da vorschreiben? Nee. Geht das? Das hab ich... Wie macht man das? Kann das nicht
Dynamic sein? Oder muss Select sein? Ach nee, der weiß, hm, ja gut, der weiß ja logischerweise,
weil das Dynamic ist, weiß der nicht, dass es irgendein Linkgedöns sein soll. Ja, das
würde jetzt in der dynamischen Sprache wie Paisen ohne Probleme funktionieren. Äh, das
heißt, ich brauch ein Result-Type. Okay, ich, ich mach ein Result-Type. Sind wir mal, sind
wir mal nicht so. Also, dann ist das hier nicht getJsonAsyncDynamic, sondern, ähm,
haben wir eine Klasse draus, heißt Cloud, CloudflareResult. So, CloudflareResult enthält
ein Array. Super, das hat sich ja, das hat sich ja super gelohnt, das da anzulegen. Äh,
enthält, ja, brauchen wir noch was anderes, Klasse, CloudflareDomain. So, und das enthält
ein Array CloudflareDomains. Und heißt Result. Und in den Domains gibt es jetzt Name, also
ein String, Name. Es gibt ein ExpiresEdString. Das checkt er wieder nicht, wenn es falsch
benannt ist, deswegen muss ich das jetzt so eklig lassen. Ähm, gut, DateLeft kann ich
dann, kann ich dann nachher machen, wenn das denn war. ExpiresEd. Ich bin mir nicht sicher,
ob der JSON Serializer das checkt. Wenn nicht, muss ich sowas drüber schreiben, wie es wirklich,
wie es wirklich heißt. Aber mal gucken, mal gucken, ob er das checkt, da bin ich mir nicht
ganz sicher. Also, Result, wir wollen das da haben und nicht mehr Dynamic. Also, schauen
wir mal, warum ist mein, warum ist mein Console-Write-Line kaputt? Oh, Result. Schauen wir mal, was da
rauskommt. ReactOS heute. Ich komm so auf ReactOS. Lul. ReactOS, haben wir uns doch
schon mal angeguckt. ReactOS, ReactOS war unsinnig zu verwenden. Übrigens, guckt mal,
wenn ich da jetzt ein Record draus mache, dann ist die Ausgabe gut. Nee, da auch ein
Record draus machen. Dann ist die Ausgabe gut, glaube ich. Weiß ich gar nicht. Nee,
das kann er nicht. Okay. Hätte ja sein können. So, da können wir was vom letzten Mal verwenden.
Guckt mal. Wir hatten doch das letzte Mal nur so eine super 5-Headige Extension-Method.
Ich weiß nicht mal genau, was es macht, aber das war richtig Big Brain. Das machen wir
jetzt hier einfach wieder rein. Das ist immer gut, Code verwenden, wo man keine Ahnung mehr
hat, was es macht. So, und ich glaube, man könnte jetzt sowas hier machen. Nee, aber
ohne, ohne Console. Gucken, ob das funktioniert. Hey, und wir haben eine Debug-Ausgabe. Ja,
das haben wir letztes Mal im Stream zusammengewurschtet, irgendwie sowas. Das habe ich aus dem Stagoverflow-Post
ein bisschen verbessert. Der Jason serialisiert das Object und deserialisiert es wieder und
dann nimmt er den Output hier. Da kann man sich besser... Okay, also Expires funktioniert
gar nicht mit der Umfrage. Was, wie, wo? Ach so, das ist ein Vorschlag. Das muss jetzt
irgendein Mod so nett sein. Ach Leute, wir haben ja die Umfrage vom letzten Mal noch
gar nicht aufgelöst. Sekunde. Prediction. Oder? Chat? 5-Head Mods? Haben wir das das
letzte Mal aufgelöst? Oh. Sekunde, Leute. War eh ein Scammer an der Tür gerade. Okay,
ich versuche gerade die Prediction. Wie beendet man die Prediction denn? Wie lange bis Max
den Api trocken liegt, war die letzte Umfrage. Übersicht. Ne, Choose Outcome? Choose Outcome
kann ich nicht machen. Weil das wahrscheinlich letzten Stream war. Moment. Prediction? Nö.
Ne, Moment. Der hat es doch schon. Passt schon. Ist schon alles durch. Der Serious Max hat
es richtig gemacht. Der hat das abgehakt. Prediction vom letzten Stream. Alles gut,
plötzlich hat es sich erledigt. Also das mit dem Expires Ad checkt er nicht. Gucken wir
mal hier, ob er es so kapiert. Expires Ad. Alles klar, gut. So, das war schon die bisschen
bessere Variante. Ja, es ist eine richtige High IQ Moderation hier wieder. Also Result.
Jetzt sollte das nämlich auch funktionieren, was ich hier mache. Select. Okay, so und jetzt
habe ich hier die ganzen, was ist denn das? Wie nennt man das hier? Domains oder so? Keine
Ahnung. Genau, wunderbar. Domain, Punkt. Name. Das Casten kann ich mir jetzt sparen. Expires
Ad kann ich mir jetzt sparen. Time left. Ne, die ReactOS Umfrage musst du nicht starten.
Das ist komplett unsinnig. Also gut, jetzt haben wir den ganzen Krampen und wie kriege
ich den jetzt gescheit ausgegeben? Wie kriege ich das gescheit ausgegeben? Also für ein
Zabbix brauchen wir, haben wir gerade gesehen, brauchen wir irgendwie so eine Ausgabe. Array,
bla, bla, bla, bla, bla, bla. Also quasi sowas hier sinngemäß. Array und dann sowas
wie Domain, Doppelpunkt, Kapalul.com und dann irgendwie Expire und so. Irgendwas in
der Richtung. Das müsste, das müsste ja relativ einfach gehen. Ich kann jetzt einfach sagen
Jason Serializer, Serial, was? Ne, nicht Serializer, ist ja falsch. Jason Convert, Serialize Object,
Domains. So und das müsste ja da schon ungefähr passen, was ich hier als Output raus bekomme.
Äh, achso, Ausgabe sollte ich vielleicht noch machen. Ja, das sieht doch schon ganz brauchbar
aus, guck mal. Name, Kapalul, Expiration Date, Time Left. Alles gut, das finde ich nice.
Vielleicht sollten wir den Kram noch gescheit nennen. Den nennen wir Domain, das nennen
wir Date oder so und das nennen wir Left. Ist wurscht, wie wir das nennen. Hauptsache
das heißt irgendwie ein bisschen sinniger. Ok, also kriegen wir jetzt raus, Domain, Kapalul,
Date, Expire Date, Time Left. Wobei, Moment, das ist ja richtig hängen geblieben. Was
für eine bescheuerte Ausgabe. Ne, ne. Time Left muss in Seconds sein und das sollten wir
als Unix-Time machen. Wie kriege ich denn das jetzt als Unix-Time? Ne, ne, das ist
schon, das ist schon ok. Moment, wie kriege ich denn jetzt, ich will das hier, das hier
als Unix-Time haben. Date, Time Offset und das kann ich jetzt Unix-Time, 2 Unix-Time
in Seconds. Ok, mal gucken ob das funst. Ok, wunderbar. Also Domain, Kapalul, Expired hier
an Unix-Time und das sind, ne es ist im Moment nicht Seconds, Total Seconds. Meine Güte.
Ok, das ist eigentlich genau die Ausgabe, die ich brauche. Domain, Kapalul, Date ist
Expired in Unix-Time und Left ist das hier, das ist ok. Interessiert einen bei Domains
die Zeit wirklich auf Sekunden-Ebene? Ne, aber das kannst du im Zabbix oder im Prometheus
ja dann anzeigen, wie du lustig bist. Ja vielleicht sollten wir es wirklich ein bisschen anders
nennen, das ist hier Expired-Date und das hier ist irgendwie Time Left. Wie sage ich
so das Shutter-Jason-Naming, macht man das da überhaupt so oder macht man das mit Bindestreich?
Oh Unix-Timestamp. Pfeifer-Idee. Aber da weiß man nicht, da weiß man nicht Timestamp für was.
Das müssen wir Expire vielleicht nennen. So, das nennen wir Time Left Seconds. Komm mal,
das sieht dann tatsächlich halbwegs brauchbar aus. Domain. Da können wir das auch noch
Domain Name nennen und dann sind alle happy. Also ich finde schon, dass es sinnvoll ist,
also ein Grund warum es sinnvoll ist in Sekunden das zu machen ist, wenn du wirklich in Graf
malst damit, jetzt über Prometheus, Grafana, dann siehst du wenigstens den Tag über die
ganze Zeit wie es runterläuft, ansonsten würdest du immer nur sehen wupp wupp wupp wupp wupp
so eine Treppe. Domain-Champ. Das können wir mal minimieren, das brauchen wir jetzt nicht.
Gut, das sollte als Output reichen für ein Subbix und jetzt muss ich gucken wie man das
als Prometheus-Exporter macht. Das müssen wir eh mit zwei verschiedenen Kommando-Zeilen-Parametern
machen. Das mache ich dann zum Schluss wenn ich, übrigens wo wir gerade dabei sind theoretisch
habe ich euch jetzt schon gezeigt können.NET Watch Run machen und dann jedes mal wenn
ich jetzt was ändere, jedes mal wenn ich jetzt was ändere, ist wenn ich zum Beispiel
sage, ah das Ding soll doch Name, Domain Name oder so heißen, dann drücke ich einfach
save und dann führt es gleich wieder aus. Dann sage ich, ah nee ist doch nix, dann ändere
ich es wieder zurück, zack speichern und dann fühlt es automatisch aus. Also theoretisch
kann man das. Wie kann ich ein.NET kompilieren? Hast du da einen Tool-Vorschlag? Ah, dekompilieren.
Ja, EL-Spy und.NET Peak ist beides ganz nice. Ich weiß aber nicht was die coolen Leute
heutzutage verwenden. Also EL-Spy ist gut und.NET Peak ist das JetBrains Ding..NET
Framework machen die auch. Ich glaube EL-Spy ist sogar mittlerweile relativ beliebt auf
Shithub. Ja, gibt es aber keinen. What are you doing? I try to monitor my Cloudflare-Domains
for expiration date. Why that I don't miss when they expire? Ackerman, genau. Am besten
benennt man jede einzelne Variabel X und Schachtel. Also meine Lieblingsbenamung von
Variablen ist tatsächlich Temp oder Blob. What if they do? Maybe if I miss it completely
some other guy will register the domain. Realistically nothing will happen. Ich glaube nämlich nicht
dass jemand kappalull.com und omega-keckel.com mir jetzt wegschnappen will. Ich will meine
Domains nicht automatisch erneuern. Ich kann das auch machen. Ich will die Domains nicht
automatisch erneuern. Also manche Domains habe ich automatisch erneuern, aber nicht
alle. Weil manche Domains weiß ich nicht ob ich die behalten will. Und selbst wenn
ich die auf automatisch erneuern habe werde ich zumindest durch das Monitoring dran erinnert,
dass ich die Dinge immer noch auf automatisch erneuern habe. Nee manche Sachen will ich
nicht behalten. Ja guck mal ganz im ernst. Warum sollte ich kappalull und omega-keckel
verlängern? Das habe ich jetzt einfach nur für den Stream gemacht. Aber trotzdem gucke
ich wann die ablaufen und dann fliegen die irgendwann aus dem Monitoring raus. Ok also
das hier ist die Zubix Ausgabe. Zubix. Das machen wir mal weg. Jetzt ist die Frage, wie
macht man denn? Cloudflare schickt hier Mails? Doch ich glaube Cloudflare schickt Mails.
Aber wenn man Monitoring daheim hat schon, dann kann ich mir doch gleich noch einen schönen
Graph machen wo ich sehe dass es abläuft. Das sieht dann so aus hier guck so wuiiii.
So also wie macht man nochmal ordentliche Prometheus-Exporter in.net? Also nur mal so
als Beispiel wie so ein Prometheus-Exporter aussieht. Ich bin mir gar nicht sicher ob
ich einen Node-Exporter hier drauf habe. Node-Exporter. Doch habe ich. Ich installiere den mal ich
zeige euch mal wie so ein Prometheus-Exporter aussieht. Ach da ist er. So. Localhost 9000.
IP liegt das. Matrix. So also so sieht das standardmäßig aus. Der Prometheus geht alle
Minuten zu den Hosts wo die Exporter drauf laufen und sammelt diese ganzen Metriken ein.
Das sind jetzt natürlich ziemlich viele Metriken weil das ist quasi der komplette Standard
Node-Exporter für Linux. Der exportiert alles von Fallsystemen bis User bis CPU Auslastung
und alles. Also wir müssen jetzt sowas machen auch für die Domains halt vielleicht nicht
ganz so viel. Erstmal wieder löschen. Weg. Du kannst sowas auch machen für die Domains
die vergeben sind. Ja kannst du machen. Da musst du irgendwie gucken wo du die Infos
als her bekommst ob die Domains wieder frei sind. Du kannst wenn du Glück hast kannst
du mit WhoIs gucken. Also außer de-domains bei de-domains geht das nicht. Also bei manchen
Domains gehts. Im WhoIs steht drinne wann der Kram abläuft. Also wenn du drauf spekulierst
dass du die Domain wegschnappen kannst dann kannst du dir das auslesen wann es wieder
soweit ist. Uptime-Kuma kann nur Zertifikate. Zubix kann auch keine Domain-Expiration und
Grafana und Prometheus auch nicht. Du musst da was eigenes für bauen. Es gibt ein paar
Node-Exporter die das über WhoIs machen. Aber WhoIs ist halt gerade für de-domains
auch nicht zu gebrauchen. Deswegen mach ich was eigenes was das über meinen Registrar
abfragt. So also wie macht man denn jetzt einen Prometheus-Exporter in.NET? Summaries
Track Trends in Events oder? Any Numeric Value. Gut das will ich haben. Counters, ne sowas
sowas will ich haben. Schon eine Weile her das haben wir schonmal im Stream gemacht.
So mal kurz mal schauen wie macht man sowas jetzt gescheit? Ich bin ich bin nicht mir
ist nicht ganz klar wie das funktioniert. Oh Example? Gibt's da eben Example für? Oder
brauche ich da ein Web? Muss es ein Webprojekt sein? Ah das muss ein Webprojekt sein weil
ich ne ich kann auch einfach sagen New Matrix Server. Ok das ist eingebaut. Es muss kein
Webprojekt sein ok. Also New Matrix Server. Schauen wir mal wie man das jetzt auf die
Reihe kriegen. So Matrix Server. Local Host Port. Ja 1 2 3 4 soll mir recht sein. Ich
mach mal kurz ich mach mal kurz das Watch aus. So Matrix Server. Schauen wir mal und was
brauche ich jetzt? Ich brauche jetzt irgendwas was das Ding exportieren kann. Nehmen wir
mal das da. Mein. Und dann? Einfach ne Endloschleife. Ja gut warum nicht. Jobs in queue. Value gleich
random. Warte mal. Wir lassen wir machen mal kurz. Wir lassen ihn mal kurz eine Runde
random Zeug. Random. Next. Next. Int. 64. Beste. Es geht nicht weil. Aha. Set. Ok.
Next Double. Und jetzt kriege ich einen Server auf 1 2 3 4 der mit Matrix Server oder wie?
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt ob das so einfach funktioniert. Local Host 1 2 3 4. Wenn man
Doppelpunkt dazwischen machen würde. Nordfond slash Matrix. Easy. Das ist ok das ist einfach.
Das ist eine gute Library. Versteht man wie es funktioniert. Doch wir haben ein PR gemacht
für Uptime Kuma. Das haben wir. Also wir wollten. Wir wollten. Ich habe es aber nie
gemacht. Wir wollten. SSL Zertifikate. Wir wollten eine Übersicht für SSL Zertifikate
einbauen. Dass dann irgendwie Expiration ordentlich dasteht. Habe ich aber nie gemacht
und zumal ich Uptime Kuma auch nicht mehr im Einsatz habe. Also die Library ist nice.
Das finde ich gut. Kriegt man hier. Ich meine ob jetzt. Das ist jetzt relativ wurscht aber
wichtig ist das hier. Jobs. Das ist das was ich hier randomise. Guckt wenn ich abfrage
ändern sich die Werte auch einmal in der Sekunde. Also hier oben. Guckt da. Was der
Matrix Server macht. Den kann Prometheus jetzt abfragen. Wenn ich jetzt ein Prometheus
starte und Scrap Config rein mache für den Server abfragen. Dann steht das da drin.
Das machen wir jetzt. Das machen wir jetzt auch. Ich werde jetzt ein Prometheus. Ich
meine den Docker Container mit Prometheus und gut ist. Worüber machst du jetzt. Ich
mache Zappix aktuell. Zappix macht aber mehr als nur Ping. Ich weiß mein Passwort für
Zappix habe ich gerade nicht. Da muss ich den Passwort Manager gucken. Wer spielt denn
heutzutage noch? Okay. Docker Prometheus. Müssen wir mal gucken. Wir starten mal ein
Prometheus Ding. Wobei wir brauchen dafür noch nicht mal ein Docker Container. Das ist
ein Go Binary mit 30 MB oder so. Konfig müssen wir eh anlegen. Prometheus Config. Schauen
wir uns doch mal an ob das jetzt funktioniert. Wir brauchen irgendeine Scrap Config. Irgendeine
Minimal Config. Example. Das sind irgendwie so 5 Zeilen. Das ist nicht viel. Hier genau.
Das braucht man. Easy. Das ist alles. Und wie nennt man das? Prometheus.YAML. So. Alle
15 Sekunden einsammeln. Das ist ziemlich egal. Das braucht man nicht. Das kann man sich sparen.
Scrap Config. Job Name. Alles okay. Alle 5 Sekunden. Alle 5 Sekunden fragt er ab. Das
ist ja aber sportlich. Local Host Port 1234 hatten wir gesagt. Jetzt sagen wir Prometheus.
Und dann minus F. Glaube. Nee. Minus Minus. Minus Minus. Konfig File. Ach es ist Punkt
YAML. So und jetzt läuft mein Prometheus und er sammelt alle paar Sekunden hier von
die Werte ein. Mal davon abgesehen, dass er ziemlich unsinnige Werte einsammelt, weil
ich aktuell random Ausgaben mache und nicht wirklich meine Domains abfrage. Also wir können
jetzt ja mal checken ob der Kram funktioniert. Mal mal ein Grafana. Docker starten. Und den
verbinden wir dann mit dem Prometheus und dann gucken wir ob es funktioniert. Grafana
Docker Image. Port 3000. Jawoll. Das wollen wir haben. Grafana Run. Minus Minus RM. Dass
da wieder wegfliegt danach. Grafana kann das? Das ist richtig. Relativ easy. Restart.
Docker. Warum auch immer. Docker wieder irgendwelche Netzwerkprobleme hat. Ups. Äh. Äh.
Wo genau ist jetzt dein Problem? Fail to host Sandbox operation not supported? Das
war's für heute. Wir sehen uns beim nächsten Video. Bis dann.
Schauen wir mal ob Reboot geht. Was haben wir heute für den Hintergrund? Chat
wer ist Fiveheader und erkennt was es ist im Hintergrund? Ich erkenne es nicht. Frankreich?
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Barcelona? London? Chat. Ja was ist es denn jetzt? Rechts ist ein
Cock. Ok. Yep. Brasilien? Kappa? Ok ihr wisst das genauso wenig was es ist. Ich weiß
nicht. Barcelona ok ich glaube das. Ich glaube es euch. Barcelona haben die meisten Leute
jetzt gesagt ich glaube euch jetzt das es Barcelona ist. Weil ihr es seid Chat. Ihr
wisst es auch nicht. Aber Barcelona haben viele Leute gesagt das glaube ich jetzt einfach
mal. Ich weiß nicht was ich für einen Hintergrund habe weil ich habe ein Hintergrund austausche
das heißt wenn ich Reboot habe wird mein Hintergrund ausgetauscht. Das ist das Bing
Image of the Day. Der einzige Service wofür ich Bing verwende ist dafür. Run. Rider heißt
jetzt Twix da ist der Rider aber nicht. Ok Prometheus gestartet. Ok Docker. Run. Praege
das es jetzt funktioniert Leute. Praege. Wow funktioniert. Nice. So jetzt haben wir
Grafana am Start. Also Local Host Port 3000. Login. Boah was ist das? Grafana Default
Login. Grafana Grafana oder Admin Grafana oder so. Admin Admin. Admin Admin. New Password
ok Firefox merkt ihr das mal please. Also dann malen wir mal ein paar Crafts. Datasource.
Prometheus. Achso Moment mein Prometheus läuft jetzt ja auf meinem Host und das hier
läuft ja. Muss ich das per IP adden. So. Moin Mark. NCS. Ok Port. Wo läuft das standardmäßig?
90.90 ok. 90.90 HTTP Doppelpunkt Doppelslash. Credentials gibt es nicht. TLS gibt es nicht.
Gibt es alles nicht. Save and Test. Error Reading Connection Refused. Meint 80.80. 90.90.
Hab mich vertippt. Keckl. So. Also save and test. Gut sehr schön. Explore. Jetzt haben
wir ja unser Prometheus Campbell drinnen. Jetzt können wir mal schauen. Neues neues
Dashboard ja. Wir machen den mal über Explore. Select Matrix. So. My App Jobs Cute. Leute
da ist es. Run Query. Zack. Guck mal da. Und schon haben wir unseren eigenen Prometheus
Exporter einen massiv feilfertigen Craft daraus erzeugt. Das ist jetzt halt nicht. Das hat
nichts mit meinen Domains zu tun by the way. Sondern es ist der Test Prometheus Exporter
den den keiner braucht. Jetzt werden wir meine Domains exportieren. Also Local Host. Local
Host Port 1234 Slash Matrix. Und jetzt machen wir das aus und jetzt exportieren wir meine
Domains. Also Server Start. Random. Brauchen wir nicht mehr. Wild True. Sollen wir recht
sein. Ok wir exportieren jetzt allerdings nicht. Meine. Job Cues sondern die Domains. Wie nennt
man das jetzt. Wie nennt man das jetzt am besten. Gibt es da irgendwie so eine. Irgendwie
so eine. Naming Convention für Prometheus. Ach hier kann man Labels exportieren. Counters
wollen wir nicht. Das sieht so aus Summary's Track Trends in Events Overtime. Ne das wollen
wir auch nicht. Also wir wollen hier eine. Wie spricht man das aus. Gauge. Gorge. Gucken
wir uns mal an. Gauge. Gauge. Gauge. Gauge. Und ist es ein Unterschied zwischen UK. Die
sieht ja sehr glücklich aus bei der Aussprache Alter. Also die kommt ziemlich. Ziemlich
Kegweight. Alter. Das sieht erstaunlich ähnlich aus. Ok. Was. Alter was ist das für ein Video.
Ok ich glaube einfach dass man das so ausspricht. Ich glaube das ist richtig was wir machen.
So und jetzt machen wir sowas für jede für jede Domain. Falls das sinnvoll ist. Ich
weiß nicht. Schauen wir mal. Also Jobs. Keine Ahnung Domain. Hier haben wir die Domains
drinne stehen. Ach Moment. Das muss man jedes Mal neu abfragen. Ansonsten ist das ziemlich
unsinnig. Weißt ihr was. Ich bin mal so frei. Ich mache da keine Funktion draus. Ich mache
das einfach inline hier jetzt rein. Für die paar Zeilen. Und wir machen das Async. Genau
nicht Threadsleep. Wo kommt man da hin. Await. Task. Delay. Eine Sekunde. Wie besser. Ganz
ehrlich. Wenn ich das im Sekundentakt abfrage werde ich garantiert von Cloudflare irgendwann
gedrosselt. Sollte es vielleicht alle 30 Sekunden machen oder so. Das funktioniert so nicht
wie ich mir das vorstelle. Wie mache ich denn das jetzt am besten. Weil ich gehe davon
aus dass er jedes Mal eine neue anlegt. Also ich habe dann irgendwann Matrix Export mit
500 Domains drinne. Guckt mal. Wir können jetzt ausprobieren ob meine Befürchtungen
da stimmen. Normalerweise würde ich jetzt. Ich mache einfach da jetzt doch eine Schleife
draus. Ich glaube das funktioniert so nicht wie ich mir das vorgestellt habe. Aber schauen
wir mal. Mal gucken was jetzt passiert. Mal gucken was passiert mit der ganzen Geschichte.
Domain. Ja ja. Metric. Der legt das jetzt mehrfach an. Also sprich der Name ist jetzt
My App. Also der Name ist jetzt nicht mal App sondern ist Domain. Expire oder so. Kann
ich da jetzt den Domain Namen reinschreiben. Checkt er das. Name. Oder muss man das als
Label machen. Kein Fall. Na gucken wir mal was er macht. Wahrscheinlich muss ich das
als Label machen. Ich muss sagen Domain Expire und dann mehrere Labels oder so. Wie dynamische
Werte. Mal gucken was passiert wenn ich das jetzt anschmeiße. Schauen wir mal. Oh Mist
jetzt habe ich mal einen Grafana Container ausgemacht Schnub und er ist auch gleich wieder
gelöscht. Scrape Intervall. Eine Sekunde. Bam gib ihm. Hau rein man. Was jetzt. Ein
S oder wie. Ich muss meinen Grafana nochmal neu anrechnen. Admin. Admin Admin. Just das
ist er. Wunderbar. Schauen wir mal was der hier macht. Oh oh. Domain Expire. Ok das funktioniert
nicht. Man kann die Domains da so nicht reinschreiben. Wie würde man das machen. Ich gucke einfach
mal ab. Wie das andere gemacht haben. Domain Exporter. Ja wunderbar. Die Matrix sollten
Domain Expire Date Time Stamp Seconds sein und dann als Label die Domain. Ach so. Ja
logisch. Ja natürlich. Der Chat mittlerweile die ganzen Prime Stubs die haben schon so
gewirkt. Unter 131 EQ ist hier einfach niemand mehr im Chat. Du hast recht das ist auch vollkommen
logisch. Weil die Matrix sind ja diese drei Dinge die wir hier haben. Genau das Ding sollte
heißen Domain Expire. Äh Moment. Hatte ich den Kram nicht vorher umbenannt. Also nicht
Domain Name genannt. Ach hier unten. Ach nee so muss ich das machen. Two Unix Time Seconds
so ne. Die Musik ist zu nervös. Sekunde. Entspannendes. Jawoll. Die Sache ist die ich
will das eigentlich auch nicht im Submix ausrechnen später. Aber du hast recht es wäre ziemlich
sinnlos das zu machen. Weil ich kann das im Frontend machen. Die Time ausrechnen. Dann
lasse ich das erstmal weg. Time Left Seconds Expire Time. Also das Ding müsste jetzt heißen
so Help Text wer braucht Help Text. Ok also das Ding müsste jetzt im Endeffekt heißen
Domain Expire und dann zum Beispiel hier Expire Unix Timestamp oder so. Und dann würde ich
sagen Domain. Nee Moment das würde ich hier gar nicht anlegen. Das würde ich hier oben
einmalig anlegen. Jetzt ergibt das doch auch Sinn oder? Nee wobei ich muss es pro Domain
anlegen. Ich bin doch nicht so ganz im Klaren darüber wie es wirklich funktioniert. Also
Domain Metric Set. Und da würde ich jetzt sagen Expire Unix Time. Alles klar. Und hier
würde ich noch Labels setzen. Hier würde ich jetzt noch sagen Label Names also sowas
wie Moment wie setzt man die Dinger? Nee wie setze ich überhaupt? Achso und hier würde
ich jetzt sagen Domain Name als Label. Ok. Schau mal was da rauskommt. Oh. Grip. Kappa
Lul. Was? Wie kriege ich denn die Domain jetzt in mein Label Name rein? Ok. Ok. Ok.
Wie würde man ein Domain als Label setzen? Macht das mal ein Anführungszeichen? Nee.
Wenn ich das Anführungszeichen mache dann ist das ein ganz normaler String und nicht
Kappa Lul. Nee der stört sich an dem Punkt. Der stört sich eindeutig an dem Punkt. Da
darf kein Punkt drin sein. Da darf kein Punkt drin sein. Aber wie kann ich denn ein Domain
Label machen? Ok das gestaltet sich komplizierter als ich mir das vorgestellt habe. Oder muss
ich vielleicht sowas hier machen? Domain? Gleich? Aber das sind nur Label Names. Also
würde ich sagen Label Names Domain? Und gibt es jetzt Label? Label? Set oder so? Achso Domain
Metrik. Aha. Remove Labeled with Labels? Was? Label Values? Ok jetzt wird es mir zu
advanced. Moment. Also Value ist ja eindeutig der Domain Value. Labels? With Labels? Ich
habe keine Ahnung was ich mache. Label Value? Domain Name? Aber woher weiß er dass er das
und das jetzt zuordnen soll? Mal schauen. Mal gucken ob es jetzt läuft. Ok ok. Postchamp?
Moment. Wait a minute. Fast. Fast. Ach kommt. Ach so muss das gemacht werden. Jetzt habe
ich es gecheckt. Ah ja. Exzellent. Exzellent. Komm mal jetzt funktioniert das Domain. Expire
Unix. Time stamp. Domain omega cackle.com ist das und da und da. Expire das. Stimmt
genau. Und das Create kann da jetzt raus. Das ist richtig. Äh hier. Jetzt ergibt das
auch Sinn. Weil jetzt der muss das ja nicht jedes Mal anlegen. Das reicht ja wenn er
das einmal macht. Ok das ist nice. Das finde ich gut. Ah hier. Domain omega cackle.com
zack zack zack. Jawoll sehr schön sehr schön. Delay 5 Millisekunden. Na ja. Komm wir machen
das mal auf eine Minute hoch. Wir wollen ja oder auf 61 Sekunden falls es auf 60 Sekunden
timet irgendwie. Wer programmiert lieber in C++? Das kann ich mir beim besten Willen
nicht vorstellen dass es Leute gibt die sowas machen. Ok das sind meine Domains. Warum exportiert
der eigentlich standardmäßig? Kann man dem nicht abgewöhnen dass er die Standarddinger
exportiert? Das will ich überhaupt nicht haben. Metric Server dem kann man doch bestimmt
sagen dass der diesen Müll nicht standardmäßig exportiert oder? Du programmierst lieber
in C++ als in? Der Registrar weiß ich nicht. Es ist ja immer Cloudflare eigentlich. Tatsächlich
sowas gibt es? Ah ja gut doch. Ich kann es zwar nicht nachvollziehen aber ich kann mir
die Situation vorstellen warum das so ist. Wenn du microcontroller Sachen und sowas
machst ja dann bleibt dir nicht viel anderes übrig. Ach stimmt ein zweites Label. Ja ein
zweites Label würde ich vermutlich einfach nochmal. Set? With Label? Ne. Das ist tatsächlich
gut. Wie kriegt man ein zweites Label rein? Einfach so oder? Ach ne Moment. Ne warte mal.
Wie mit dem? Stimmt. Wie macht man ein zweites Label? Ha. Das ist tatsächlich. Wie macht
man ein zweites Label? Wahrscheinlich muss man Set? Labelt oder so? Ah Moment ne ne ne
passt schon. Der Wert gibt es ja nur einfach. Es gibt ja nur einen Wert. So also hier könnte
ich jetzt zum Beispiel dann auch. Ja es kann keine schlechte. Also muss man dann hier oben
sowas sagen wie Domain, Registrar sowas hier und dann quasi hier Cloudflare. Das müsste
jetzt eigentlich funktionieren oder? Denke ich mal. Ja Registrar gleich Cloudflare. Pipehead
Time. Geballte high IQ Kraft aus dem Chat am Start gewesen. So jetzt haben wir den Prometheus
Exporter Cloudflare. Wir könnten das theoretisch auch hier oben abfragen, weil wenn wir. Hab
ich irgendwo noch den Jason Output davon? Moment Leute. Ich muss mal kurz nochmal den
Jason Output besorgen davon. Blub. Jetzt String. So perfekt. Da stand noch der. Ah ja ja.
Registrar steht doch da irgendwo drinne. Kurz noch JQpipen, dass ich da irgendwas sinnvolles
drinne erkenne. Steht da Registrar hier nicht drinne? Hier. Current. Current Registrar steht
da drinne. Das brauche ich noch. Und zwar meine Classes hier Cloudflare Domain. Wo stand
das drinne? In der Domain? Ja also quasi hier String. Das da. Bin immer begeistert, wie
viel Copy Paste Arbeit das ist. Current Registrar. So das sollte jetzt funktionieren und an der
Stelle kann ich jetzt anstatt Cloudflare reinzuschreiben einfach Domain. Current Registrar wie
auch immer nehmen. Moment. Sack. Schwachsinn. So. Und jetzt wenn ich Refresh sollte es da
eigentlich alles richtig. Oh. Hier. Guck da. Cloudflare. Passt. Nice. Hast du schonmal
was für Micradoc gemacht muss PDFs rennen lassen? Nein. Hab ich nicht. Ok cool. Das
tut. Das bedeutet auch ich kann mein Grafana wieder einrichten. Add data source Prometheus.
Ahja. HTTP. 9090. Save. Save and test. Und jetzt. Explore. Select Matrix. Domain Expire
Unix Timestamp. Run Query. Da sind wir. Komm mal hier. Alles da. Domain Expire Timestamp.
Moment. Aha. Ja. Das ist natürlich klar. Das ist jetzt auch so ein Ding was ich persönlich
ein bisschen doof finde an Prometheus. Der Kram verschwindet erst wenn es aus der Datenbank
verschwunden ist nach frag mich nicht. Ich kann aber einfach die Sache runter stellen
dann sollte also letzte keine Ahnung. Letzte paar Minuten oder so dass es dann halt raus
fliegt. Last hour. Doch kann man. Die einfachste Variante die Prometheus Datenbank zu flaschen
ist. Du kannst es aber auch über die API machen. Jetzt muss er erstmal neu abfragen.
Guck. Jetzt muss er erstmal neu abfragen. Guck zack. Jetzt muss er noch ein bisschen
warten bis das vielleicht noch ein paar Sekunden mehr abgefragt hat. Weil so sieht das ziemlich
beschissen aus. Jetzt haben wir hier unsere Werte am Start. Und zwar. Moment. Rechnet
er das selbst aus. Das ist die Zeit. Wollte ich gerade sagen. Das ist die Zeit die aktuelle
Zeit zu welchen Punkt ich auf der Linie bin. Ok. So. Jetzt kriegen wir die Unix Timestamp
für die Domain. Ok. Als nächstes brauchen wir noch die anderen Werte hier draus. Also
wir brauchen ein Create Domain Expire Unix Timestamp. Dann brauchen wir das nicht Domainmetric
sondern Domain Expire Metric. Und ich könnte eigentlich einfach mal das Rename Feature
verwenden. Was? Aus irgendwelchen Gründen? Achso der mag nicht weil es doppelt ist. Rename.
Das Control RR. War 5 Header Time. Das wusste ich nicht. Das ist nice. Also sprich RR. Doch
das Expire wollen wir im Grafana berechnen. Achso Moment. Wir brauchen ja nichts weiteres
oder? Das andere ist ja nur der Name. Der Name den habe ich ja schon. Ne stimmt wir brauchen
gar nichts mehr. Das ist tatsächlich alles. Mehr brauchen wir wirklich nicht. Ok gut.
Dann legen wir jetzt mal ein Dashboard an. New Dashboard. Wait a minute. Ich glaube ich
hab mich verklickt. Discard. Browse. New Dashboard. Ne ich hab mich nicht verklickt. War richtig.
New Dashboard. New Panel. Äh warte mal Panel Name. War das hier oben? Das haben die umsortiert
von ein paar Versionen. Dashboard Name ist. Äh Domain. Status. Äh ja passt. So. Schön
fettes Panel. Edit. Panel Title. Oder war der Title hier jetzt? Expire. Ok Edit. Also
da muss jetzt unser Query rein. Panel. Genau. Select Matrix. Expire Unix. Ach ich wollte
gucken ob der Matrix, ob man den Matrix Server nicht sagen kann, dass er nicht diesen ganzen
Müll exportiert den ich gar nicht brauche. Aber geht glaube ich nicht. Da müsste ich
irgendwie reingucken mal was, was. Das ist wahrscheinlich standardmäßig was der alles
exportiert. Wäre jetzt die Frage wie das, wie das funktioniert. Prometheus wo hab ich
denn auf hier? Default, irgendwie Default. Suppressing Default Matrix. Guck mal ich bin
nicht der Einzige der sowas machen will. The library provides some sample Matrix. Matrix
Suppress Default Matrix. Ok. Machen wir. Sonst ist zu viel Gedöns was da geschrieben
wird. Matrix. Suppress Default Matrix. Und nochmal neu starten. Guck mal ob jetzt, jetzt
sollten nämlich nur noch meine Domainsachen. Ja. Viel besser. Und nicht so viel Shit was
in der Datenbank drinne steht am Ende. Bei Prometheus wenigstens das Problem aber Zabbix
hat Schmerzen mit Daten. Das ist auch das was ich bei Zabbix im großen Stil bisher gemerkt
habe was die meisten Probleme macht ist die wenn du zu viel History speicherst. Das Ding
ist lahm. Wobei es angeblich seit TimescaleDB besser geworden ist. Kann ich aber natürlich
von meiner Installation zu Hause nichts zu sagen, weil die paar Sachen die ich daheim
sammle haben nicht genug um den Zabbix in Straucheln zu bringen. Aber wir hatten ja
auf der Arbeit tausende Systeme drinne und ihr könnt euch vorstellen es waren 3000 Linux
Systeme ungefähr und davon massig Metriken pro System. Bei Zabbix sind es ja eigentlich
eher Checks. Die Datenbank war glaube ich am Ende 2TB oder so. Oder mehr. Ich glaube
irgendwie um die 2TB. Und die hatte richtige Performance Probleme. Könnte aber auch an
Zabbix Leuten gelegen haben. Weiß nicht ob die das nur nicht wussten wie man das richtig
macht. Keine Ahnung. Aber ich schiebe es mal auf Zabbix. Ich muss euch ja vorstellen das
ist 3000 Linux Systeme. Massig Metriken pro System und das dann irgendwie noch 2 Jahre
oder 3 Jahre wie sie das aufbewahren gestellt haben. Das konntest du komplett knicken.
Für die Zertifikate braucht man keine History. Das ist richtig. Wenn man einfach nur wissen
wie es jetzt ist. Wenn man wissen will ob die Verlängerung und so alles funktioniert
ist History schon nicht verkehrt. Aber bei so Sachen wie RAM Auslastung, Disk Space und
so. Da willst du History haben. Warum die das damals bei uns 2 oder 3 Jahre später auf
ein Jahr runtergestellt haben. Warum man das so lang gesammelt hat ist fragwürdig. Man
hat sich damals davon versprochen man kann halt historisch erkennen zum Beispiel wenn
neue Versionen deployed worden sind. Über das letzte Jahr wie der RAM Auslastung. Es
hatte schon einen gewissen Sinn. Aber allgemein es zu sammeln war tatsächlich sinnvoll. Weil
du konntest relativ gut erkennen. Okay Probleme drehten ab 2 Uhr nachts auf. Dann bist du
in Zabbix gegangen hast das Ding auf 2 Uhr nachts gestellt und hast dir mal die Graphen
angeguckt für RAM, CPU, IOU und so. Und dann hast du auch ein paar Server nebeneinander
hast du relativ schnell erkannt an welcher Stelle irgendwas kaputt ist. Ja in Prometheus
ist das ganze eh nicht so das Problem. Die Datenbank ist für solche Sachen gemacht.
Die Zabbix Datenbank nicht. Wobei wie gesagt mit TimescaleDB mag das jetzt besser sein.
Das kann ich aber nicht beurteilen weil ich noch keinen großen Zabbix mit TimescaleDB
gesehen hab. Und es gibt ja in Prometheus auch die Möglichkeit Langzeit Archivierungsdinger
noch anzudocken. Wo bin ich jetzt stehen geblieben? Achso wir wollten ein Dashboard anlegen. Domain
Expire. Be No Data. Ahja. Last 15, 6 Stunden ist vielleicht ein bisschen viel. Aber letzten
15 Minuten. Saven wir das ganze mal kurz. So der Graph sieht ziemlich beknackt aus. So.
Die haben das umsortiert. Früher war das hier unten. Und seit irgendwie einem Jahr oder
so ist es hier rechts und ich finde es seit demnächst mehr. Weiß nicht ob es noch irgendjemand
so geht. Seitdem die dieses Panel umsortiert haben finde ich nichts mehr im Grafana. Muss
ich jedes mal ewig lange suchen. Früher war das hier unten drunter. Irgendwie habe
ich es da besser gefunden. So als würde ich erstmal die Legende anpassen. Ich weiß gar
nicht mehr nach was ich da suchen muss. Ne das muss man hier unten machen oder? Options.
Genau. High IQ Craft Alter. Genau so will man das haben. Custom. So ging das genau. Domain.
Ja. Das sieht schon deutlich besser aus. Da weiß man nämlich. Da weiß man nämlich
was es ist. Das Domain kann ich weglassen. Farben und so sollte er alles automatisch
machen. Ja stimmt. Einheit muss ich auch noch einstellen. Korrekt. Also wir sollten auf
jeden Fall noch. Ja. Ok. Wir sollten auf jeden Fall. Manchmal bin ich mir nicht sicher was
die ganzen Buttons machen. Ja wir sollten den Craft noch ein bisschen umstellen. Weil
das ist ziemlich eklig. Aber trotzdem erstmal speichern. Da ich nicht alles Doppeltreifer
machen muss. Also wie ging das jetzt nochmal? Tooltip. All. Find ich sinnvoll. Dann stehen
nämlich alle zusammen da. Und nicht nur der. Find ich ganz praktisch. Da kannst du hier
gucken und siehst immer gleich was die zu dem jeweiligen Zeitpunkt haben. Lasst ihr
das automatisch erstellen. Oben auf Time Series. Oh jetzt wirds. Jetzt wirds. Etwas. Der Chat
weiß was. Also Zeichner. Time Series. Und jetzt. Postchamp. Kann ich den Typ auswählen
von dem. Von dem Craft. Suggestion. Oh. Ist das neu? Das ist mir noch nie aufgefallen
dass es das Panel gibt. Ist das neu? Ok das gibt es seit einem dreiviertel Jahr oder so.
Ich glaub das kann die Grafana Version bei uns auf der Arbeit noch nicht. Geh ich mal
davon aus. Das hab ich ja noch nie gesehen. Das ist aber cool. Das ist sehr nice. Das
erredet quasi was du haben willst. Mal ganz davon abgesehen. Das ist ja überhaupt nicht
das was ich haben will. Das ist ja überhaupt nicht was ich haben will. Ich muss erstmal
die Einheit jetzt einstellen. Wir machen das jetzt mal von Hand. Also irgendwo konnte man
Unit. Unit. Choose. Unix. Time. Nee. Oh Gott. Time. Time. 1KS. Ich hab. Ach du Scheiße was
könnte. Moment. Grafana. Unit. Unix. Time. Was du machst. Die Zappix Auswertung mit Grafana.
Also sprich du wertest den Zappix mit Grafana aus oder du benutzt die Grafen im Zappix gar
nicht und benutzt Grafana anstatt den Zappix Grafen. Also du lässt quasi Zappix klassisch
dann die Checks machen und einsammeln aber die Grafen machst du dann mit Grafana oder
wie? Anstatt die Zappix Building Crafts. Also ich hab gelesen für Zappix 6.4 glaube ich,
also für die nächste Zappix Version wollen sie endlich ihre komischen Oldschool Grafen
wegschmeißen und dann nur noch die neuen Vektor basierten Grafen nehmen die sich auch im Webinterface
nicht so anfühlen wie von 1995. Okay. Ist nicht grad das Coole, ich muss dich jetzt
mal fragen, weil die Frage stelle ich mir nämlich daheim auch. Ich finde nämlich das
Handling für Datenanzeige so im Grafana um Längen besser als im Zappix. Aber ich finde
den vom Ansatz her für meine Heiminfrastruktur den Zappix an sich sinniger. Mit einzelnen
Holes definieren, paar Checks und gut ist. Ist nicht grad das Coole am Zappix, dass man
alles in einem hat, so hast du ja dann im Endeffekt mehr, so hast du dann im Endeffekt ja zwei
Tools. Du musst quasi deine Alerts und deine Alert Übersicht und aktuellen Probleme und
alles musst du im Zappix gucken und dich alerten lassen vom Zappix. Oder wenn du die letzten
Werte angucken willst, Host Up, Down und solche Geschichten guckst du dann im Zappix. Aber
so Sachen wie Speicherverlauf, der Festplatten und so guckst du dann im Grafana, also sprich
ihr habt dann zwei Systeme, wenn ich das richtig verstehe. Stört euch das nicht, dass ihr
in zwei Systemen gucken müsst? Ja kannst du, aber du kannst mittlerweile über Grafana
alerten oder du kannst beim Prometheus auch den Alert Manager nehmen. Ich hab mir das
neue Alerting vom Grafana noch nicht richtig angeguckt. Die haben seit ein paar Versionen
haben die Unified Alerting. Das schreib ich mal auf, vielleicht gucken wir uns das jetzt
bei der Gelegenheit auch mal an. Die haben Unified Alerting und das ist angeblich jetzt
cooler als früher, aber immer noch nicht so krass wahrscheinlich. Also das letzte Mal
war Alerts über Grafana ziemlich pepega unsinnig. Also ihr macht nur Alerts, also es heißt
im Endeffekt, ihr benutzt das Zappix Frontend gar nicht für Gucken. Ihr benutzt das Zappix
Frontend zum konfigurieren und ihr guckt euch den Zappix quasi nur über Grafana an,
wenn ihr wirklich auf die Daten gucken wollt. Ja. Das ist für das Festwürdig, ja es leuchtet
ein. Ok, also lasst jetzt mal Unit, wollte ich gucken. Unit, Unix Time. Convert Unix
Time to Date Time in Grafana. You can already convert a Unix Time Stem to Date Time. Ok
warum hat er, was? Oh jetzt kommt Grafana Fiveheader Zeug. Milliseconds? Ok Grafana möchte das
in Milliseconds haben, na geil. Also sprich, wenn ich meinen Grafana jetzt einstelle auf
Unit, Time, dann sind es 53 Jahre. Oh ey, da wäre der. Wie würde man das machen? Wie
würde man das machen? Ahja, die expecten das in Milliseconds. Also nochmal mal 1000
vorher. Boah, da hört jetzt mein Grafana Foo auf. Man müsste das irgendwie preprocessen
oder so. Chat irgendwelche cleveren Ideen, wie ich meine Time Werte multiplizieren kann
irgendwie vorher. Operations, mal 1000 in die Query, geht das? Da muss ich aber hier
oben umschalten oder auf, kann ich einfach so machen? Ach tatsächlich, easy. Wie das
war es jetzt schon? Das ist alles? Der 2023 ist richtig. Die Domains laufen ja auch 2023
ab, am 10.07. also quasi gestern in einem Jahr laufen die Domains ab. Ist das richtig?
Okay, das ist einfach. Da hätte ich auch drauf kommen können. Aber es ist Date, Time
nicht Local, es ist Date, Time, UTC, US. Okay, ich stelle es mal auf Local. Das kann
ich auch machen, ich muss mir das jetzt erstmal in Ruhe angucken. Ja, das finde ich eigentlich
ganz, ganz nice so. Eine Spalte mit Datum? Die Linie wird sich nie ändern, doch, weil
wir müssen jetzt ja noch ausrechnen, wie viel Zeit ist left? Und da ist jetzt die große
Preisfrage, wie machen wir das? Aber das Unit war wieder weg, ist eigentlich blödsinnig.
Kann man die nicht löschen? Warte, ich darf die Unit nicht löschen. Also sprich, könnte
ich jetzt einfach sowas hier machen? Minus? Minus Timestamp? Oder muss ich Timestamp davor
machen? Ne. Oh, da habe ich keine Ahnung, wie man das Prometheus Query technisch gescheit
macht. Toys Query Timestamp. Now. Okay, da bin ich zu 3-Head für, wie das funktioniert.
Calculate time left. Würde Timeless ich habe? Keine Ahnung. Ich mach, chat, wenn ihr Ahnung
habt, wie das funktioniert, dann sag, dann einfach nur Time geht nicht. No data. Wait
a minute. Doch. Aha. Aber. Äh. Doch nicht mal 1000? Das
sieht besser aus. Das sieht besser aus. Und jetzt? Unit? Ne. Ach du Scheiße. Ach du Scheiße.
Äh. Local? Warte mal, irgendwas ist da. Irgendwie ist da eben, ist das Müll. Oder
muss ich das jetzt? Was sind das jetzt? Seconds? Time Seconds? 52 Wochen. Äh. Das ist, glaube
ich, gar nicht mal so verkehrt. Ergibt das Sinn? Aber was ist? Warum muss ich das doch
nicht mal 1000 rechnen? 2-5 Stunden kommt hin, ja. Aber kann man, warum kann ich das
jetzt nicht auf Tage? Also. Ne, ne, ne, ne. Seconds. Ja, ne.
Ähm. Wie kann ich den jetzt sagen lassen, dass ich es nicht in Wochen angezeigt haben
will, sondern, sondern, äh, in Tagen? Ich meine, ich sage ihm ja hier nicht, was er
anzeigen soll, sondern ich sage ihm in welcher Einheit das Query ist. Ich bräuchte dazu
Display Unit oder sowas. Gibt sowas auch? Oh. Kannst du irgendwie den Settings einstellen?
Ja, gucken wir mal. Hier. Ne. Jetzt, wir machen erstmal was anderes, weil das ziemlich, ziemlich
blöd aussieht. Ähm. Nein, ne, ist eigentlich ganz okay. Ich wollte jetzt eigentlich gar
nicht so viel mit Krafana rumdingsen hier. Aber das funktioniert. Ich meine, es geht
jetzt sekundenweise, sekundenweise runter. Halt in einem Scale immer von 52 Wochen, ja.
Aber vom Prinzip her funktioniert das ja. So. Na gut. Also. Dann haben wir einmal den
Grafen, wie auch immer. Grafana Display Time Days. Ja, also ich weiß nicht, wie man das,
wie man das, das, da müsste ich mich jetzt ein bisschen beschäftigen mit. Ich vergesse
die ganze Grafana Geschichte immer, wenn ich da eigentlich zwei Tage nichts mitgemacht
hab. Und wie gesagt, seitdem es auf der rechten Seite ist, blicke ich da eh nicht mehr durch.
80. Einfach, einfach 80. Okay, kann ich mitleben? Und da drüber?
Kann man da Unit jetzt? Kann ich da jetzt sagen Days? Dann weiß ich nicht, wie es funktioniert.
So, aber das lassen wir jetzt. Und jetzt machen wir wirklich noch eine Tabelle oben rein. Table.
Zack. So, und da schreiben wir jetzt nicht. Da schreiben wir jetzt nur den Timestamp rein.
Was schreiben wir jetzt in die Tabelle sinnigerweise rein? Time left brauchen wir. Time left. So.
Und das hier sind jetzt Sekunden, bis das abläuft. Dann haben wir das gleiche Problem.
Unit. Es sind Sekunden, bis das abläuft. Das steht jetzt wieder in Wochen da. Letzte
15 Minuten, ist doch okay. Ist doch Absicht. Und das, ich hätte das halt jetzt gerne in,
sagen wir mal, in Stunden oder in irgendwie, dass da was Sinnvolles dasteht. Müsste ich
jetzt. Okay, mal was, mal was anderes. Wenn ich das hier jetzt umstelle auf. Mach mal
mal testweise was. Unit. Wenn ich eben sagen, das sind nicht Sekunden, sondern Tage. Nee,
dann rechne der das auch hoch. Okay, da weiß ich nicht. Da müsste ich mal gucken, wo man
den Output. Grafana Output Unit. To force the output of statspanel grafana to only show
values in days. Was? Stack, Stack Overflow, Stack Overflow immer beste. Das stimmt doch
überhaupt nicht aus Schwachsinn. Nee, das ist Blödsinn, was die schreiben. Egal, eigentlich
wollte ich gar nicht so viel Grafana Zeug rumspielen heute. Ja, ich könnte das selbst
ausrechnen, aber es ist doof, dass ich selbst ausrechnen muss. So, jetzt haben wir noch
eine Tabelle. Machen wir noch die Legende mal anders sagen, dem hier Custom Label Name
Domain. Zack. Kappa Lull. Wie stellt man jetzt die Tabelle ein, dass der mehrere Sachen anzeigt?
Kein Schimmer. Schwarze Magie, Alter. Instance Domain. Das will ich alles da gar nicht angezeigt
haben. Das will ich da doch alles gar nicht. Ich will doch einfach, ich will auch die Timeline
nicht angezeigt haben. Wo kann man jetzt einstellen, was der in der Tabelle alles anzeigt? Columns
Filter. Aha. Nee. Was? Keine Ahnung. Ja, Columns Filter hätte ich jetzt auch gedacht.
Aber ich weiß nicht, was der da filtert. Oh, Monkeys. Ja, weil ganz ehrlich, da steht
so viel unsinniger Schwachsinn drin, will ich da gar nicht drin stehen haben. Edit. Grafana.
Table. Hide Columns. Siehst du, ich bin nicht der einzige, der das will. Hide Columns in
der Tabelle. Use Transformation named Organize Fields. I've had time. Transform. Was? Okay,
das ist wirklich 6-Header, 6-Header-Time hier. Aha. Time weg. Instance weg. Job weg. Registrar
weg. Da Registrar kann man dalassen. Boah, das ist ja mal wirklich Next Level 6-Head.
Das ist das Tool hier. Transformation Date. Ich würde gerne was sehen. Okay, das geht
nicht so. Und jetzt noch eine Query ohne das Minus Time. Äh. Noch eine, du meinst noch
eine Extra dabei. Ach so, dass wir beides anzeigen lassen können. Wow. Jetzt ist, jetzt
ist vorbei. MonkaS. Jetzt ist, jetzt ist broken. Jetzt ist kaputt. Ah, nee, ist nicht kaputt.
What the fuck, Alter. Transform. Applying a Joint Transformation. Woah. Alter. Jetzt
ist aber hier wirklich 5-Header-Time angesagt. Okay, Join. Domain. Nee. Warte mal, auf was,
auf was will ich überhaupt Join? Wobei, das ist doch okay. Moment, das ist doch, das ist
doch gar nicht so verkehrt jetzt. Alter. Value A, Value B. Name. Registrar kann da
bleiben. Ja. Okay. Value A is time left und Value B ergibt irgendwie wenig Sinn. Value
B sollte eigentlich Expired Date sein. Muss ich deshalb mal 1000 rechnen, weil er sonst
nicht checkt? Oh nee. Durch 1000? Nope. Ach, deswegen in Sekunden. Boah Leute, das wird
zu, zu high IQ jetzt gerade. Da, wo sich das, das ist wieder zu anstrengend. Also, ich
mein, so ungefähr, so ungefähr das, was wir haben wollen, kommt jetzt da raus. Save
Dashboard. Leute, das Dashboard ist so 6-Headig, das muss ich mir exportieren, bevor ich denke,
bevor ich die Grafana Instance lösche. Moment, wo ging das? Wo konnte man den Kram exportieren?
Nee. Du wirst das Dashboard kaufen. Auf geht's. Jason Model, war das? Ach ja, genau. Kann
man das nicht einfach speichern? Ah ja, okay. Das ist, das ist 6-Head. Das speichere ich
mir jetzt. Save as 5-Head Dashboard. Bei links ist das? Nee. Nee, nee, Save as, das ist
fürs Grafana. Ich will es ja runterladen. Ich will es ja downloaden. Der Chat ist richtig
5-Head gewesen. Okay, das ergibt so ungefähr Sinn, was hier drin steht. Das mit den Einheiten
müsste man sich da nochmal überlegen. Das ist jetzt nicht so gut durchdacht, aber das
passt. Leute, ich habe keinen Bock, den Zabbix jetzt zu machen, aber wir könnten den Zabbix
auch gar nicht machen, weil ich das Tool noch nicht umgebaut hier für, dass es im Zabbix
funktionieren würde. Zabbix ist abfuck, da habe ich jetzt irgendwie gerade keinen Bock
drauf. Zumal das jetzt hier im Zabbix gar nicht funktionieren würde. Ich müsste jetzt
erstmal Kommandozeile, ich müsste jetzt erstmal das Tool umbauen, dass man beides verwenden
kann. Das machen wir aber. Ich hatte doch letztens so ein GitHub, Kokona hieß das doch,
so ein Kommandozeilen Application Framework für.NET. Kokona. Leider falsch geschrieben.
Zumindest, ich meine, in dem Fall bräuchten wir kein Kommandozeilen Framework. Ganz ehrlich,
man könnte einfach gucken, ARKS, einfach schauen, ob das Argument quasi Minus Minus
Exporter oder so gesetzt ist. Aber ich mein, hey, warum nicht irgendeine Kommandozeilen
Framework nehmen, wenn es funktioniert. Also. Zack. Also Run, String, Name, nein nicht Name.
Warte, das muss weg. Das muss weg. Also, kurz den Kram mal auscommenten. Also Kommandozeilen
Application, also String, Name, ne, Bull, Exporter, so Exporter. Das heißt, if Kommandozeilen-Argument
ist Exporter, dann macht er diesen ganzen Shit von da oben. Ansonsten ist es Zabbix.
If Exporter, dann Flop. Normalerweise würde man das jetzt noch auslagern, aber mein, warum?
Run, Async, alles klar, wunderbar. Reformat, dass es wieder schön aussieht. Und das kommt
raus. Ok, das heißt, wenn ich das Ding jetzt starte mit Minus Minus Exporter, dann macht
er daraus den Node Exporter. Ups. Was hat er jetzt für Schmerzen? Ich glaube, ich hab's
einfach zu früh abgebrochen. Marfinius Raid mit drei Leuten, Dankeschön für den massive
Pfeif hätt ich in Raid. Oh, was jetzt? Also wenn wir Minus Minus, guck mal, wir können
jetzt sogar Minus Minus Help angeben, wir haben jetzt einen automatischen Hilfetext.
Guck mal. Automatischer Hilfetext. Also Domain Matrix. Also Minus Minus Exporter startet
wieder den, machen wir noch eine Kommando-Zeilen-Ausgabe, dass man weiß, was da abgeht. Starting Matrix
Server on port 1234. Weil ansonsten checkt ja keiner, ob das gestartet wurde. Export.
Es gibt ziemlich viele Command-Line-Dinger mittlerweile, ja. Nicht in, in port, on port,
on port. Ja, ich weiß, ich weiß. Ich hab mir letztens alle möglichen Command-Line-Frameworks
eingeguckt. Okay, Starting Matrix Server on port 1234. Exis hier, HTTP, Doppelpunkt, Doppelslash,
1, 2, 3, 4, so. Kann man hier auch draufklicken, zack. Moment, es ist ja auch nicht, es ist
Slash, Slash Matrix. So, jetzt weiß man wenigstens Bescheid, was da abgeht. So, und wenn es nicht
Exporter ist, dann will ich, dann will ich den Kram für ein Zabbix exportieren. Ich
da keinen Bock drauf hab, jetzt Zabbix zu machen. Aber okay, mein, steht im Titel, wir
müssen Zabbix machen. Also, if exporter, ansonsten else. Ich sollte ganz ehrlich diese
Abfrage hier mal in irgendeine, komm, wir machen, mach hier oben irgendeine Funktion,
keine Ahnung. Fetch data, Async task, Cloudflare Results, Turn, Fetch data, Secrets. Possible
Null Reference, nee, kann nicht sein. Gibt's bei mir nicht. Sowas kann bei mir nicht passieren.
Ich hab Null Reference rausgepatcht aus meinem.NET, ich bin safe. Moment. Eigentlich ziemlich
unsinnig, dass ich das hier awaite und es dann, naja, gut, egal. Data Result, alles gut.
So, jetzt kann ich den Kram hier abfragen. Hier kann ich es nochmal abfragen und da
machen wir jetzt irgendein Zabbix Ding draus. Hier, Console Output, Data. Mehr muss ich
da glaube ich nicht machen, dann ist schon, nee, Moment, nicht Data. Schwachsinn. Hier,
den ganzen Krempel muss ich da noch machen, was die so blöd sind hier. Du hast Recht,
wenn man es nicht awaitet und das Ding Exception schmeißt, weiß man nicht was abgeht. Tja,
du hast Recht. Korrekt. Ja. Äh, warte mal. Äh, es sind jetzt ja auch kein Cloudflare
Result mehr, sondern, immer. Na, da wäre ich mir jetzt nicht so sicher. Ähm, sondern
Data Result Select. Und wenn das der Kram, den ich da unten weggeschmissen habe. Paints
Champ Result. Ja, so nennen wir das Ding. Gute, gute, gute Idee. Werde ich gleich machen.
Ähm, Return New Paints Champ Result. Create Type Paints Champ Result. Domain Name. Ähm,
Expire Time Left Seconds. Achso, den gibt es ja dann auch gar nicht. Oh, kann man das?
Moment, kann man das da automatisch jetzt hinzufügen lassen? Nee, oder? Das, das wärs
jetzt, Alter. Was du hier machst, ich mache, ich mache High IQ Graphen für meine Domains,
wenn die ablaufen. Ok, dann nennen wir das so. So, zack. Paints Champ Result. Wo ist
es? Paints Champ Result. Paints Champ Result. String. Domain Name. Äh, was hatten wir
das hier? Hast du schon vorgefertigte Dashboards? Nee, wozu? Das ist ja der eigene Exporter
von mir. Äh, Expire. Unix Time und äh, Time Left Seconds. Aber das ist kein String, sondern
das ist ein Unix Time, äh, nee, nee, nee, nee. Wie heißt das? Time Offset? Nee, Quatsch,
das ist kein Time Offset, das ist einfach ein Int64. Und das ist auch ein Int64. Warum?
Weniger Speicher. Unsigned. Ja, das kann doch nicht negativ sein. Achso, Moment. Wait a minute.
Doch, das kann negativ sein. Das kann negativ sein. Weil, es könnte ja auch sein, dass
Time Left Minus ist und dann ist es nämlich schon abgelaufen. Aha, ja. Ok, aber Unix
Timestamp kann nicht negativ sein. So, nö, das ist nicht 64, wahrscheinlich nicht. So,
und jetzt kommt das hier, passt. Also, Domain Name. Domain Name. Expire. Expire. Und als
letztes Time Left. Time Left Seconds. Zack. Total Seconds. Wo ist jetzt das Problem schon
wieder? Pains Champ, Mann. Warum geht das denn? Äh, das ist auch falsch. So, wat, wat? Ach,
das ist, das ist gar kein Int. Warum ist Two Unix Times Zack? Doch, das ist doch. Ach,
Time Left ist ein Times. Das ist hier was? Ein, das ist ein, das muss ein Double sein.
Ein Double soll mir auch recht sein hier. Und da hat er jetzt Schmerzen? Ok, ja, es
ist gut. Alles klar. So, meinetwegen. Gut. Und jetzt? Ist das als Result? Ist das ein
Pains Champ Result? Array. Return. Nee. Oh nee, es ist ein, ein, kein Pains Champ Result,
es ist ein I Enumerable Pains Champ Array. Irgendjemand braucht mir eine Hilfe, der leckt
das Stream. Da werd ich nicht viel machen können, wenn bei Leuten das Stream leckt.
Was soll ich, was soll ich da tun? So, das braucht man alles nicht mehr. Kann man nämlich
einfach sagen. Domain. Name. Domain. Ah, jetzt hab ich den Registrar nicht gespeichert,
ich kack noob, Alter. Lul. Expire Unix Timestamp kann ich aber setzen. Domain. Expire Unix
Timestamp. Ja, komm. Dann den Registrar auch noch rein.
Registrar, gleich. Ok, wunderbar. Reicht. Auf geht's.
So, so bleibt es. Hallo? Kann das mal weggehen, das Hilfefenster. Hilfefenster. So bleibt
es jetzt. So, jetzt haben wir nämlich den Kram hier unten ein bisschen entschlackt und
setzen das jetzt. Das kann nicht null sein, weil ich sage, das kann, wenn ich sage, das
kann nicht null sein, dann ist das nicht null. Leute, mein, meine Idee ist am abkacken. Guck
mal, das Havang geht gar nicht. Ach mal, Multiple Iteration. Lul. Warum? Wo iteratet der Multiple
Times? Ich seh's nicht. Ach, da unten. Nee. Ich räum manchmal auf, nicht immer, warum
ist hier Multiple Iteration? An welcher Stelle? Ach so. Ja, Moment. Der hat ja auch recht.
Das muss ja auch da rein. Gibt ja auch keinen Sinn, das muss da rein. Ok, passt. So, und
jetzt kommen die Zappix-Geschichte, Fetch-Dings, ok, also ohne Exporter, jetzt kommt der Zappix-Output.
Domain Name, Kappa, Lul, Expire, Unix Time, Time left, Seconds, Registrar, Cloudflare,
ok. Das ist der Zappix-Output und das andere ist hier der Prometheus-Output. Ok, wunderbar.
So, alles, alles gut. Ich müsste jetzt eigentlich den Raspberry Pi anmachen, wo der Zappix drauf
läuft. Es ist ganz großes Pains-Champ jetzt, sowas im Zappix zu konfigurieren. Aber wir
haben noch Zeit, wir haben noch Zeit, 18 Uhr ist erst Pippo-Fat-Time. Also ich finde
aber Pains-Champ Result ist ein guter, guter Name. Und das hier brauchen wir nicht. Was?
Das brauchen wir eigentlich nicht, weil es da theoretisch nie hinkommen kann, weil das
hier Endlosschleife ist. Das soll mir jetzt zurecht sein. Alles gut. So, jetzt haben wir
das, jetzt, ich mach mal nebenbei, Leute, ich mach mal den Raspberry Pi an. Schadet ja
nix. Könnt auch mal gucken. Also hier ist die SSD. Wo ist das Stromkabel? Da ist ein
Stromkabel. Wo führt das hin? Leute, der Tisch ist äußerst pepega aufgeräumt. Raspberry
Pi anmachen. Zack, geht da an. Wunderbar. Muss mal kurz in meinen Router gucken, was
der Raspberry Pi für eine IP kriegt. IP DHCP Server Leases. Mal warten bis der sich
meldet. Ach, Leute, ich hab den gleichen Rahmen gemacht wie das letzte Mal. So dumm.
Ich hab den Switch nicht eingeschaltet. Wo der Raspberry Pi dranhängt. Das ist natürlich
sehr clever. Da wird es bestimmt sofort funktionieren. Kekl. So, jetzt hab ich den Switch eingeschaltet.
Ich hoffe mal, dass es funktioniert. Was macht eigentlich mein Grafana so? Das Grafana hat
vor sich hin. Auto Refresh, please. Achso. Auto Refresh geht ja nicht, weil ich hab hier
meinen Node-Exporter aus. So, was kriegt der mal für eine IP? Raspberry Pi 2.1.3.2.
Hatten wir den das letzte Mal hier auch schon? 2.1.3.2. Aha. Poggers. Uptime. Okay, das
ist auf jeden Fall der richtige. Und jetzt ist die Frage, ist das der mit dem Zabbix
drauf? Okay, das ist der mit dem Zabbix drauf. Update. Also das ist der Test Zabbix, wo wir
das letzte Mal Zabbix installiert haben und uns das ein bisschen angeguckt haben. Das
ist nicht mein Zabbix, den ich hier lokal laufen hab. Das ist nur für den Stream gewesen.
Okay, also 1.2.1.3.2. Zabbix, da sind wir doch schon. Zum Glück hab ich das Passwort
gespeichert. Hätte ich im Leben nicht mehr gewusst. Okay, solche Dinger hatten wir da.
Config. Hosts. Ja, genau. Okay. Tests. Test-Dinger für den Zabbix. Alles klar. Okay. Das wird
was. Ich sag's euch, Leute. Wie? Also mein Zabbix ist übrigens auch der Meinung, Test-Host
ist down. Was auch korrekt ist, weil Test-Host ist wirklich down. Disk-Space-Free. Warum ist
das ein Warning? Ach so. Okay, das Warning ist aber auch richtig hängen geblieben gesetzt,
ja. Guck mal. Wir haben das Ding auf irgendwie einen Terabyte noch was gesetzt oder 940 Gigabyte.
Jetzt sind es halt 88, die frei sind. Ja, immerhin. Ganz toll. Zumindest der Zabbix funktioniert.
Alles gut. Was haben wir eigentlich für eine Zabbix-Version? Gibt's da nicht was Neues
mittlerweile? Abt. Info. Zabbix. Ne. Server? Ach man. Install. Da ist ne Krampel. Ach hier.
Zabbix-Server-PSQL. Wir hätten wahrscheinlich auch Wildcard machen können oder das vorher
versuchen. Wir haben Zabbix-Version 6.0. Gab's da nicht letztens Zabbix-Release 6.2? Dann
upgraden wir den jetzt schnell nochmal. Okay. Alles klar. Upgrade. Das Upgrade ist easy.
Upgrade Procedure für Ubuntu. Oder wie man das richtig ausspricht. Also was sollen wir
machen? Zabbix-Server Stopp. Mach ich. Backup. Ich mach doch kein Backup. Wo kommen wir denn
da hin? Leute YOLO. Entweder geht das Ding nach einem Backup noch oder er fliegt weg.
Ganz einfach. Hier wird kein Backup gemacht. RM. On Ubuntu 20.04. Warte. Was haben wir denn
überhaupt? Debian-Version. Das ist. Ah. 11. Okay. Gut. Alles klar. Also das da. Zack.
Was? Okay. Die Fault Action ist. Also was wollen wir haben? Wir wollen die Differences
zeigen. Zabbix Source. Wie auch immer. Package Maintainer Version. Wunderbar. So jetzt haben
wir Zabbix neue Version installiert. Erstmal mal ein Update und dann ein Upgrade. Oh. Skipping
Architekture. Was? Hä? Was? Was ist das? Was ist das? Was ist das? Was ist das? Was
ist das jetzt verstehen? Ich hatte den Kram noch vorhin. Ich hatte den Kram das letzte
Mal noch auch installiert. Oder musste man ein anderes Repo nehmen für den. Für den
für den Raspberry Pi. War das ein.
Keine Ahnung. Aber. Dann löschen wir es nochmal. Begett. Ja. Oder haben die noch keine
Arm Repos. Was auch immer das war. Aber ich glaube ist alles okay. Postgres Repo will
irgendwie nicht ab Upgrade. So das müsste es doch gewesen sein. Yes. Upgrade. Start.
So schauen wir mal. Bin mal gespannt. Ob mein Zabbix nach dem Upgrade noch läuft.
Ja ja. Security Hinweise. Erstmal alles wegklicken. Moment warum installiert er mir Apache und
sonst was da drauf? Ich dachte, dass ich dachte, mein Zabbix läuft über den Engine X da drauf
und nicht über. Nicht über Leute, ich glaube, mein Zabbix ist danach im Arsch. Ich glaube,
das ist RIP. Ich glaube, ist gleich dead. Ich habe Apache ausgewählt. Was? Wo? Du meinst
hier ein Web Interface oder so? Nee, das ist nicht. Das ist nicht schlimm. Ich habe es
zumindest aus. Warum habe ich da Apache überhaupt installiert? Und warum habe ich Grafana installiert
da drauf? Ich habe auf jeden Fall noch mehr gemacht auf dem Raspberry Pi als da nur Zabbix
drauf zu installieren. Sieht so aus. Du meinst hier? Hier beim Download? Nee, das ist eigentlich,
das ist nicht so wild. Das ändert sich nur, was er hier unten macht. Guck, ob er Apache
reinschreibt oder ob er Engine X reinschreibt. Aber das habe ich ja eh nicht installiert
was die da schreiben. Ok, drei Stunden Upgrade. Ok, Start. Ich habe da ein Grafana drauf gemacht?
Warum? Ok, keine Ahnung. Also Zabbix Server. Server Version. Tammern. Alter! Warum hast
du nicht geupgraded? Warum hast du nicht geupgraded? Was ist das hier? Der hat nicht geupgraded?
Der hat einfach keinen Bock. Hä? Ich bin verwirrt. Aus irgendwelchen Gründen hat das
Update überhaupt? Alter Pains Champ ey. Hä? Ich habe doch eindeutig was neueres installiert.
Oder sag gibt es? Was ist das denn? Moment, da ist der Agent. Was zum Teufel ist das denn
hier? Ok, ich habe keine Ahnung was der für Schmerzen hat. Der will nicht. Install Zabbix
Punkt. Habe ich irgendwas falsch gemacht? Soll ich mal irgendeine random Anleitung im
Internet raussuchen? Biget? Was auch immer die da machen, das habe ich gemacht. Das habe
ich doch alles richtig. Upgrade Zabbix. BGS. Wer ist das Ding? Hä? Ist dem egal oder? Hä?
Also ich meine ich habe das neueste Package runtergeladen. Ich kann mir höchstens vorstellen
dass die keine Arm Packages haben. Guck mal das ist genau das gleiche was ich hier habe.
Was? Was sagt? Abt? Policy? Zabbix? Habe ich das richtig schreibt? Es sagt Version Table.
Das neue gibt es überhaupt nicht. Im Debian Package? Kennt er? Ich habe es ja schon 500
mal runtergeladen oder so. Kein Schimmer alter. Selber kompilieren ja ist klar. Der
hat überhaupt kein Zabbix Repo. Der hat überhaupt kein Zabbix Repo mehr. Das ist das was ich
hier gelöscht habe. Guck ich habe hier gesagt. Ich lösche das Zabbix Repo und dann mache
ich das Zabbix. Vielleicht sollte ich das nochmal kurz. Ich weiß nicht warum die wollen
dass man Debian Pakete runterlädt. Das ist das ist das ist. Ich mache das nochmal. Alles
weg. Inklusive Konfig Files. Search. Auf GBM. Update. Jetzt findet er es. Aber jetzt will
er jetzt sagt er mir. Das Arm Dings nicht supportet. Kann das sein dass der 6.2er noch
keine Arm Packages hat? Dass sie das verschusselt haben oder verbummelt haben oder? Weil das
sollte so nicht sein. So was sagt denn diese komische andere Anleitung hier? Bestmonitoringtools.com
ja klingt super vertrauenserweckend schon. Die machen hier genau das gleiche. Guck mal.
Die laden sich das Package runter. Ist genau das gleiche was ich auch hatte. Die installieren
das Package. Und die sagen Update. Und er sagt mir das gibt keine Arm Packages. Oder
doch jetzt? Ne. Ich bin äußerst verwirrt. Jetzt ist ok oder was? Update. Ach ich darf
nicht Debian. Ich muss irgendwie die Raspian Version oder so. Ich hab Debian All runter
geladen. Was in der offiziellen Zappix Anleitung steht aber das ist falsch. Ich muss Debian
Raspian oder sowas komisches runterladen. MonkaS Alter. Da soll mal einer drauf kommen.
Upgrade. So gucken ob der Zappix. Ach so warte ich sollte den vielleicht mal verstoppen.
Ja auf fahr dich runter Zappix. Upgrade. So jetzt aber. Jetzt will er den Kram auch upgraden.
Ok. Alter schwere. Obviously. Komplett obviously. Also Zappix Server wollen wir das diff angucken.
Ich hab Raspian OS ausgewählt aber das hat ihn nicht interessiert. DB Passport übrigens
Passport Leak by the way wo wir gerade dabei sind. Ich will meine Version behalten. Die
nächste Config da will ich auch meine Version behalten. So und jetzt Start. Und jetzt hoffe
ich mal. Alter guck mal Pog ich hab da unten ein Grafana. Im iFrame. Komm der ist her.
Warum ist da unten ein Grafana in meiner Timeline drin. Das muss ich da eingefügt haben aber
ich weiß nicht weshalb ich sowas gemacht haben sollte. Zappix Server Version has changed
new version 6.2. Es hat funktioniert. Gut sehr schön. Poggers. Pog like this. So und
jetzt können wir unsere unsere Checks auf den auf den Zappix kopieren. Gut also Repos
Cackle. Hier ist das. Hier ist das.NET Programm. Ähm. Beziehungsweise kann ich auch hier machen.
Also hier ist unser.NET Programm. Self Contained. Publish Trimmed Enable Compression Single
File. Linux ARM heißt das glaube ich das richtige. Moment das falsche Framework Version. Abbrechen
.NET Publish. Ach was. Hier wird nichts getrimmt das dauert nicht so lang. Hier wird nichts
komprimiert und hier wird nichts getrimmt. Aber Single File will ich haben. Publish Single
File. Publish Single File. Wird nix getrimmt und nix sort. Das darf ruhig richtig pepo
fett sein dieses Package. Das ist mir egal. Bild. Cackle da ist. 61 MB. Normalerweise
ist das. Was war unser letztes Binary 12 20 oder so. 61 MB. Richtig massive pepo fett
alter. Wir könnten übrigens ein Binary bauen wie das letzte Mal. Warum ist die Musik aus.
Wir könnten ein Binary bauen mit dem Dockerfile vom letzten Mal. Aber Moment. Das ist ja dann
X86. Ich brauche es ja als ARM. Das heißt ich müsste ein QEMU ARM Container oder so machen.
Dass ich das Cross Compile könnte. Ne ne da bleiben wir mal hier bei. 1 3 2. SCP. Bild.
Cackle nach Pi add 1 2 1 6 8 2 1 3 2. Das richtiges fettes Binary ist das. Massive fett.
Schauen wir mal wo wir hier sind. Mal gucken ob das Cackle Binary läuft hier drauf.
Wait a minute warum läuft das Binary nicht. Linux ARM. Ist es Linux ARM 64 vielleicht.
Ok SCP. Ah. Ok. Das ist natürlich jetzt PP gar. Das wäre normalerweise nicht so. Das ist
weil ich mein Cloudflare Secret nicht im Stream leaken wollte. Hab ich das in diese
Datei reingeschrieben. Ja. Deswegen muss ich das jetzt rüber kopieren. Das ist eigentlich
normalerweise nicht so. Secrets. Weil ich möchte mein Cloudflare Secret nicht leaken.
So. Schon viel besser. Also. Das sollte jetzt eigentlich Zabbix Output hier haben. Hey Funst.
Mein Mail Provider scheint irgendwelche komischen Experimente mit Wasm zu machen.
Und nun kann ich nicht in mein Mail Postfach. Das sagt. Prinzipiell würde ich sagen ist sogar
ganz gut wenn der E-Mail Provider Experimente mit Wasm macht. Vielleicht macht es im Endeffekt
dann die ganze Sache schneller in Zukunft. Es sollte aber auf jeden Fall nicht dazu führen
dass ein E-Mail Postfach nicht mehr geht. Was hast du denn für ein E-Mail Provider.
Ok. Also. Dann gehen wir mal in die Zabbix Scripts. Etc. Zabbix. External Scripts. Nee.
External. Ach Scheiße. Zabbix. External Scripts. Wo müssen die Dinger hin. External Check.
Warum ist Zabbix technisch alles so unglaublich kompliziert. User. Lib. Zabbix. External Scripts.
Alles klar. Obvious. Da hätte ich es vermutet. Proton Mail. Wir haben einige Leute im Chat die
auch Proton Mail verwenden. Chat wie sieht es bei euch aus. Habt ihr auch Probleme?
Habt ihr auch irgendwelche Probleme. Das werde ich nicht Secrets aufmachen.
Ok. Ihr habt also auch Probleme.
Ok. Jetzt schauen wir mal ob wir den. Nein. Ich will immer nach vm bleiben. Jetzt schauen
wir mal ob wir den Zabbix irgendwie konfiguriert bekommen. Ok. Configuration. Was habe ich
da eigentlich für den Zabbix Theme ausgewählt. Mein Zabbix sieht anders aus den ich habe.
User Settings. Profile. System Default. Blue. Dark. Also mein Zabbix sieht anders aus.
Kann es sein das es hier am Cashlit. Nein Leute mein Zabbix sieht etwas anders aus
den ich habe. Das ist aber auch ein 6 Zwei. Muss man nicht. Muss man jetzt nicht verstehen
oder? Oder ich bin im Kopf einfach zu pepega und check schon gar nicht mehr. Ok also jetzt
müssen wir den Check konfigurieren dass da die Domains abfragt. Also das heißt wir legen
jetzt mal einen neuen Host an im Zabbix. Create Host. Das Ding heißt einfach Domains. Da kann
ich alle Domains rechecken weil unterhalb von einem Host macht es jetzt ja relativ wenig
Sinn. Host Groups muss sein. Irgendwas hier. Alter gibt es nicht irgendwas. Ja Hypervisors
genau da muss da rein. Agents brauchen wir nicht. Add. So. Items. Jetzt kommt Zabbix extremste
Big Brain Konfig. Also was die Russen sich da ausgedacht haben ist auch nicht mehr normal.
Wobei ne nicht Russen äh Litauer oder wo kamen die her? Zabbix? Ne Litauen oder so sind
die glaube ich. Oder Estland oder so. Könnte Estland sein ja. Da muss man ja heutzutage
aufpassen. Ey wenn du zu denen wahrscheinlich sagst Russen dann ist das ja quasi direkt
Beleidigung. So also was können wir. So create item. No interface found. Oh nein. Wir wollen
aber auch kein wir wollen ein external check haben und zwar ein external check der sich
Kekl nennt. Ja ok das heißt hier Domain. Expire oder so ich weiß nicht wie ich es nennen
soll. Key Kekl. Update Intervall. Update Intervall eine Minute. Update Intervall 10 Sekunden.
Ist das eine Pflicht dass man ein Host Interface hat? Geht das sonst nicht anders oder? Braucht
der Hosten? No interface found ok. Warum braucht man. Warum braucht man Zabbix in Interface
wenn der überhaupt keinerlei checks in der Richtung hat? Zabbix logik muss man nicht
verstehen Interface. Ancient ok alles klar perfekt. Aus Lettland kommen sie. Ne zum testen
ist das ist das gut mit 10 Sekunden. So also items. So Zabbix check. External check. Kekl
name. Expire Domain. Keep history. Ja komm ich keep my history rein zum testen. Wie das
jetzt wie das jetzt ist. Eine Drenz. Das ist halt auch das coole an der ganzen Grafana
Geschichte bzw. an der Prometheus Geschichte. Den kannst du wirklich zackig einsammeln lassen.
Ach guck mal Protonmail sagt auch auf Twitter dass sie gerade Probleme haben. Tja. RIP.
External check. Add. So und wenn das jetzt funktioniert sollte ich hier unter latest
data sehen dass der check was abgefragt hat. Latest data. Mal einfach mal hier. Execute
now. Ist das überhaupt ausführbar mein Skript? Kekl ist ausführbar. Ah Moment. Für. Für.
Das kann er nicht ausführen. Ja. Oh. Could not find file. Secrets and. Warum ist doch
da. Muss ich das ins Zabbix Heimatverzeichnis kopieren oder was. Alter da hab ich mir da
hab ich was gebaut mit diesem Secrets File dass ich meine Credentials nicht im Stream
leake. Ok erstmal was anderes. CHMOR777 Nummer um auf nimmer sicher zu gehen. Das ist auf
jeden Fall funktioniert. 777. Secrets auch alles klar. Wo erwartet denn der Zabbix diese
Secrets Datei. Could not find. Slash Secrets Inc. Moment. Der führte den Kram ins. What
the fuck. Ist mir egal ich schmeiß eh das Token danach weg. Ich kopiere es jetzt einfach
dahin. Hauptsache es funktioniert. Ok. Next please. Execute now. Zabbix ist nicht so schnell.
Zabbix schon spät. Zabbix müde. Auf Zabbix. Time out while executing a shell script. Hab
ich schon gesagt dass ich Zabbix ziemlich umständlich finde. Leider ist das. Das ist
das was ich meine. Es sacken alle Monitoring Lösungen. Kafana Prometheus ist an sich cool
aber für sie dieses einzelne Haus Monitoring bei mir daheim nicht unbedingt der Weisheitsletzter
schluss. Ok. Zabbix. Moin x Max 1 1 5 muss das ich muss das irgendwie hochstellen Zabbix
ist in der Agent Conf. Time out. Ach meine Güte. Crap. Time out. Das kann man hochstellen.
Das script läuft dann länger als zwei Sekunden. Ja. Time out. Hä da war ich doch gerade drinne.
Hier. Da will ich hin. Ich hab es klein geschrieben. Time out 4. Time out 30. Nix hier. 30 Sekunden
Time out. Auf gehts. Das ging aber schnell. Läuft seit 19 Sekunden. Wo ist denn das Problem?
Ah ja. Ok. Aber da steht schon das richtige drinne. Ok. Das klingt sinnvoll. Das ist nicht
funktioniert. Wir wollen auch nicht numeric. Das ist Text. So. Next please. Execute now.
Zabbix komm. Mach einfach. Zabbix hat keinen Bock mehr. Ich weiß ich hab euch auch umgestellt
dass ihr nicht mehr numeric seid. Hey. Also wir lernen daraus. Execute now ist in Zabbix
logisch sowas wie execute mal innerhalb der nächsten halben Minute please. Obwohl der
nichts großartiges zu tun hat kommt ihr auch noch dabei. Ok. Der soll nicht einmal alle
15 Sekunden ausführen. Execute demnächst. Genau. So. Also jetzt hab ich meine JSON Daten
schon mal im Zabbix und jetzt kommt ganz abgedrehter Zabbix Shit den ich nur so am rande irgendwie
jetzt zusammen bekomme wahrscheinlich weil die Zabbix also ihr habt gesehen wie easy das
ganze in Prometheus ist so dynamische Sachen hinzuzufügen einfach abfragen und fertig
und er fragt alle Domains ab. Alles mit den Labels juckt den überhaupt nicht. Beim Zabbix
ist das anders. Dass ich dem Zabbix jetzt beibringen kann ich hoffe ich krieg das aus
dem Kopf halbwegs hin. Dass ich dem Zabbix jetzt irgendwie beibringen kann dass er daraus
Werte extrahieren soll ist schon mal gar nicht so einfach und richtiger Abfuck ist es ich
muss dem Zabbix jetzt beibringen dass er daraus zwei verschiedene Domainchecks machen soll
aus diesem JSON Array. Also sprich dass der zwei Check Items daraus erzeugt weil es könnten
ja eine oder 50 Domains sein das weiß ich nicht das muss der ja automatisch discoveren.
So und dafür gibt es dafür gibt es beim Zabbix Discovery Rules ne doch richtig Discovery
Rules gibt es da und da kann man jetzt einstellen dass der sich aus diesem Item wo er hier diese
Domains abfragt verschiedene Trigger ne ne verschiedene Checks selbst erzeugt je nach
dem wie viele Domains drinne stehen. Gucken ob ich das hinkriege. So also du sollst ja
aus Expiredomain das rausholen. Ne ne ich brauch Low Level Discovery Makros und sowas
jetzt das ist richtiger richtig extremer Sixhead was man da jetzt machen muss. Expiredomain
Expiredomain keine Ahnung wie nenne ich das jetzt Expiredomain gibt es schon. Keine Ahnung
das ist Discovery. Ok und jetzt muss ich dem irgendwie sagen dass der aus dem JSON Text
also dass der dass der daraus sich jetzt die einzelnen Domains rausholt. Domain Name.
Oh Fuck Alter. Muss mal gucken wie man das jetzt ordentlich abfragen kann. Max hast du
schon ein C was? Ne. Ach jetzt oh man. Chebated Alter. Band ihn mal Please Mods. So Chebated
gibt es bei mir nicht gleich weg. Hot. Also für alle die es nicht verstanden haben das
ist typischer Streamer Chebated was es öfters gibt auf Twitch sprecht das hier mal leise
vor euch aus dann wisst ihr das das Monka Toss ist. Daraus kann ich nicht ab. Kann ich
meinem Smart TV mit einer Netzwerk Festplatte verbinden die an der Fritzbox hängt? Ähm
was kann ich meinen Smart TV mit einer ja also je nachdem was dein Fernseher so unterstützt
klar warum nicht. Wo ist denn das also woran hängt es denn? Was klappt denn nicht? Prinzipiell
kannst du das machen ich weiß nicht wie die Performance ist ob man mit einem Fritzbox
nass überhaupt nennenswert Video streamen kann oder so. Und ich weiß auch nicht über
was die Fritzbox die Sachen bereitstellt. Kann Fritzbox also Fritzbox kann auch bestimmt
nen Windows Share machen oder nen Samba Server. Ja ich denke auch doch doch ich denke das chat
wie siehts bei euch aus hatte schon jemand gemacht? Also ich denke das das prinzipiell
gehen sollte. Also wenn dein Fernseher Samba Shares einbinden kann oder im Zweifelsfall
musst du irgendwie per äh wie heißt das Ding UPNP ne äh DLNA Streaming oder so das
machen von der Fritzbox weiß nicht ob die das kann aber prinzipiell sollte das gehen.
Aber 4K kannst du wahrscheinlich vergessen. Also ich denke ich denke 4K ist die Fritzbox
der Fritzbox USB zu langsam. Mein USB USB 2.0 hat glaube ich maximal irgendwie so was
um die 25 MB die Sekunde das könnte ganz knapp reichen. Na doch das geht das geht 25 MB
aber sind ja das sind ja irgendwie keine Ahnung 200 MBit oder so 200 MBit das hat doch das
sollte gehen. Also ich denke schon das ist sorry for bash das müsste klappen. Ok wie
kriege ich denn jetzt da meine Domains rein? Also Dollar Punkt ne Domain Name oh Gott Zabbix
Config ich hab keinen Bock auf den Scheiß Alter. Zabbix Config ist immer so so wüsst
ihr so richtig so. Ich edit das jetzt einfach so und hoffe das funktioniert. So jetzt haben
wir eine Discovery Rule geedit und jetzt müssen wir in dieser Discovery Rule weil sich die
Zabbix Leute gedacht haben easy gar kein versteht jeder müssen wir jetzt einen Item Prototyp
anlegen für jedes für jede Domain die er gefunden hat. So Item war das jetzt Depend
Item? Ne doch Depend Item und zwar wir dependen jetzt an Expire Domain. So und der Key ist
also das Ding ist jetzt hier kein Domain Expire nenne ich einfach mal so. Der Key ist jetzt
ich glaube so das musste man in eckige Klammern machen dass es geht. Zabbix Leute Zabbix ich
weiß nicht ob es in CheckMK einfacher ist. Kannst du mit CheckMK einfach dynamische Sachen
checken lassen? Also kannst du mit CheckMK Domains checken? Also du musst ja von irgendwo
abfragen wo wie viele Domains es gibt und danach diese Domains checken. Also es kann
quasi 0 bis 50 Domains sein. Du musst irgendwo raus bekommen wie viele Domains sind es und
dann die Domains der Reihe nach durch checken. Okay add ich gucke. Bäm kann ich so klar
das ist dann wieder nicht funktioniert. Wo ist das Problem? Invalid Key Domain Expire.
Achso das muss glaube ich ein anderes Score sein. Du kannst das in ein Skript machen und
dann an CheckMK senden. Ja das kannst du im Zabbix auch machen. Du kannst glaube ich
über die über die Zabbix API das anlegen ja. Du bräuchtest dann quasi ein Skript was
an die Zabbix API geht dort die Checks anlegt und dann regelmäßig auch irgendwie befüllt
oder so. Das könntest du machen. Ja das ist richtig. Hey Leute Moment das funktioniert.
Das geht einfach. Der hat meine Domains discovered. Guckt euch das mal an. Er hat erkannt dass
wir Domain Omega Kekkel und Kappa 0 haben. Ich mein der Rest kann ja nicht funktionieren
weil dieses Jason nicht richtig extrahiert wird aber das geht einfach. Damit hätte
ich jetzt wirklich nicht gerechnet. Okay dann habe ich doch ein bisschen Zabbix Krams gecheckt
in den letzten paar Wochen. Aber es ist wirklich ganz ganz ganz furchtbar abartig. So also
Item Prototypes. Wir sagen ja hier das ist ein Numeric Type das ist natürlich richtig
aber wir müssen es jetzt noch irgendwie extrahieren. Zeigt mal hier wie extrahieren wir denn hier
raus jetzt was. Übrigens guckt mal wie eklig das schon ist. Expressions zu testen also
sagen wir mal hier Jason Path. So irgendwie keine Ahnung Punkt Punkt ich weiß nicht wie
man das testen kann. Jetzt muss man hier was reinkopieren und dann kann man das testen
lassen. Mal gucken ob seine Regeln stimmen. Man könnte auch sagen warum kann er den Test
nicht direkt abfragen aber nein das geht nicht. So und wie kriegen wir jetzt damit?
Chat wir brauchen irgendwas was uns Expire Time Unix Timestamp extrahiert. Hat jemand
eine schlaue Regex Idee oder so? Aber ich glaube mit Jason kommen wir da am besten hin.
Wie kriege ich hier jetzt? Also ich habe eine Variable in der Steady Domain drinne. So ich
habe eine Variable in der Steady Domain drinne. Wie kriege ich jetzt hier abgefragt dass ich
die Domain haben will? So jetzt? Omega Kecke? Ne. So schau mal net. Wie kriegt man das da
jetzt raus? Ich weiß ja auch nicht den Array Index. Zompix Jason Path. Ok die haben noch
hier irgendwie eine Hilfe. Also was kann man da oder irgendeinen Reggex oder ich muss
jetzt den Wert da draus Extracten. Boah ne alter wie geht denn das jetzt? Wie kriege
ich das denn jetzt hier raus? Also was? Root Element Current Element? Child Operator? Was
ist denn wenn ich hier einen... Das klingt irgendwie immer sehr fragwürdig. Ne das funktioniert
so nicht. Recursive Descent. Ich habe beide Domains drinne ja weil das Zappix Schwachsinn
ist. Du musst das zwei Schritte machen. Der erste Schritt ist dass er überhaupt erkennt
dass es diese Domains gibt und dann musst du dir im zweiten Schritt aus dem kompletten
Input nochmal jetzt explizit das rausholen was du brauchst. Hast aber eine Variable in
der die Domain drin steht. Es ist wirklich sehr sehr wir was sie da gebaut haben. Ok
wie kriege ich denn das jetzt raus? Filter Script Expression. Die haben ja doch irgendwelche
Beispiele. Guck mal seh dir wie easy das in Prometheus war und was das für ein Riesenakt
im Zappix ist. Hast du dich schon mal mit DNS Gedöns beschäftigt? Naja schon aber noch
ich sag mal so ich kann dir kein Bind aufsetzen aus dem Stegreif. Ich will jetzt raus also
ich will jetzt aus diesem Ding die Elemente rausholen wo der Domain Name gleich meiner
Variable ist. Gibt das hier sowas? Sowas hier hm? Sowas? ID gleich gleich? Ok also wenn
das funktioniert dann muss ich auch mal cacken eine Runde. Ok also Array. Jaja geh mal fort
hier das braucht man nicht. Gleich gleich Omega Cackle und es ist Domain Name. Wait a minute
funktioniert das jetzt? Expire Unix Timespan. Ha Null! Alter was ist das denn für eine
Sonntagsbahn? Aber das ist immer noch ein Array. First. Ok das geht aber bestimmt. Das
kann doch nicht euer Ernst sein Zappix Geist oder guckt euch das mal an. Meine Güte. Das
ist ja mal. Moment das ist nicht Omega Cackle an der Stelle. Es ist gleich gleich meine
Variable also Dom Name. Guckt euch das mal an. Das kannst du doch kein administrieren
lassen. Der kündigt dir doch noch 2 Wochen wenn er das jeden Tag machen muss. Musst du
noch mal alles. Ich hab keine Ahnung was ich machen muss. Ich rate ehrlich gesagt zum
größten Teil ob das funktioniert. Du bist gerade dabei BindConfig zu PowerDNS zu migrieren.
Was macht ihr denn für advanced Sachen? Oder PowerDNS weil Windows? Ich würde im Leben
kein Windows Zeug nehmen. Oder ist es wenigstens unter Linux? Offen wir mal. Es funktioniert
Leute. Es klappt. Der extrahiert den Expire Value. So und jetzt muss ich dem Zappix noch
sagen. Das ist ja richtig poggers das das funktioniert. Jetzt muss ich dem Zappix noch
sagen das das Unit ist Unix Time. Aber jetzt mal ganz im Ernst die Config ist wirklich
hardcore eklig. PowerDNS ist nicht Windows ok. Und warum wollt ihr dann zu PowerDNS und
von Bind weg? Ich mein ich weiß das Bind ziemlich abfuck sein kann. Also ich sag dir ganz ehrlich
das einzige DNS was ich bisher selbst gemacht hab war mit DNS Mask. Und DNS Mask ist relativ
simpel aber ich weiß auch das DNS Mask natürlich bei weitem nicht alle Features hat die Bind
so kann. Und der Debian mit PowerDNS Admin achso. Achso ok das ist für irgendwelche
Hosting Geschichten. Gibt es da nicht irgendwelche fertigen Web Panels schon? Oder ist PowerDNS
Admin in Plugin für eines der etablierten Admin Panels so? Guck dir mal da es funktioniert.
Da steht jetzt das Datum drin. Expired 10.07.2023. Es funktioniert einfach. Das hätt ich jetzt
ehrlich gesagt nicht erwartet. Dass es einfach klappt. Alle 15 Sekunden Updates da. Achja
jetzt brauchen wir ja noch eine Sache brauchen wir noch und zwar Item Prototypes. Kann man
das klonen oder so? Kann ich das nicht einfach verdoppeln? Nee. Ich muss das alles nochmal
neu anklicken. Ich hätt's gern geklont dass ich das nicht nochmal machen muss. Obwohl
ich
Okay, machen wir mal so... Man kann da draufklicken und clone?
Ha! Sixthead! Er hat es aber nicht geklonet. Ich habe einfach nur drauf geklickt und er hat
nichts gemacht. Ach nee, jetzt muss ich auf add drücken, okay. Also, jetzt brauchen wir nämlich
noch... Pass mal auf, jetzt brauchen wir nämlich noch ein calculated item, was time left heißt.
Und... Boah! Topics! Ach Gott! Nee, da hört es jetzt auf bei mir. Das ist schon ein ziemlicher
pains-champing-Kram einzurichten. Also, ich muss mir das mal angucken, wie das aussieht. Power, DNS,
admin. Ah, ein Shitter-Projekt. Ach, das ist dieses Dashboard-Ding. Es gibt total viele,
die dieses Website-Template verwenden in dieser Richtung. Ich weiß nicht, welches... Ist das
admin-LTE? Ich kenne das, das benutzen total viele, diese Geschichte. Piehole verwendet das
gleiche. Ja, gibt total viele, die das verwenden. Power, DNS, admin. Aha, verstehe. Eigentlich
gar nicht übel. Das finde ich eigentlich ganz nice. Calculated items. Hier Function,
Host. Oh, please. Last. Ok, Zabbix-Logik. Mal gucken, ob ich die Zabbix-Logik checke. Also, last. Hier
muss der Host-Name rein. Oh, fuck, Alter. Zabbix, Mann. Last Domain Expire. Ich hoffe,
dass Funktion ich hier mache. So, calculated. Last Domain Expire. Und dann minus now. Ich glaube,
oh, nee, das ist mein Browser. Ich glaube, so irgendwie müsste das funktionieren. Der Test
kannst du vergessen, weil das ist Zabbix. Da geht ja prinzipiell nichts. Ok, jetzt müsste ich ein
Time-Left-Item bekommen. Ok, so weit, so gut. Jetzt müsste die Zeit noch Calculate. So nach
50 Sekunden oder so. Wie oft updatet der denn? Ach, der updatet nur einmal in der Minute. Nee,
nee, der darfst schon alle 15 Sekunden updaten. So, wenn es geht, chat, muss ich euch was... Oh,
was ist hier? Failed. Cannot extract value from JSON. Was? Ach, ich habe das gar nicht gelöscht.
Ich kacke, Noob. Reprocessing. Brauchen wir gar nicht mehr. Remove. Das hat man nur dem anderen
gebraucht. Update. Ok. Vielleicht ist das Problem noch. Komm, mach einfach. Cannot extract.
Reprocessing. Aha, aha. Bam. Guck dir mal da. Wir haben ein Value. Der sollte auch nach unten
zählen. Wenn das aktualisiert. Wenn es wieder aktualisiert, sollte das eigentlich nach unten
zählen. Ja, change, minus 15 Sekunden. Nice. So, und jetzt? Units, seconds sind das. Last
value ein Jahr. Na, ok. Last value ein Jahr ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen... Na gut,
ich meine, es ist halt ein Jahr. Kann man jetzt nichts machen. Ich meine, ich könnte es runterrechnen
auf Tage. Warte mal. One day in seconds. 86.000 sowieso. Also sprich mal dem und dann sind
es Tage anstatt Sekunden. Weshalb genau überwachen wir Cloudflare Domains? Cloudflare Domains,
dass ich sehe, wann meine Domains ablaufen. Meine Domains laufen ab am 10.07.2023. Oh.
Was ist denn ein MD? Million? Millionen Tage? Tausend Tage? MonkaS? Ok. Moment durch. Vielleicht
sollte ich das nochmal klammern. Muss ich das teilen, Chat? Das teilen. Warte mal, ich
habe es in seconds. Nee, Moment, das ist schwachsinnig, was ich rechne. Das ist Blödsinn, was ich
rechne. Hier kommt doch Unix-Time raus. Hier kommt doch Unix-Time raus, das funktioniert
doch gar nicht. In Expire kommt doch, oder? Ich muss... Moment, ich muss das anders machen.
Ich muss das Minus now rechnen. So. Und dann mal, oder? Ich habe keine Ahnung, was ich
hier mache gerade. Kackel. Wir warten mal bis er updated. Kommen wir hier. Execute now.
Gucken, ob der das auch macht. Es ist durch 86.000. Weil ihr es seid, Chat, ich glaube euch
das. Der hat jetzt nicht wirklich aktualisiert, ne? Das hat sich tatsächlich nichts getan.
Ne, das interessiert ihn nicht. Durch?
Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung. Okay, das funktioniert so nicht. Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung. Okay,
das funktioniert so nicht. Ich weiß nicht, was ich anders machen soll. Ich bleib dabei.
Ich schweiß das wieder raus. Minus now. Okay, so. Jetzt sollte es wieder auf. Jetzt sollte
es wieder auf. Und jetzt ist es nicht Days, sondern Seconds wieder. Was? Ein Jahr, okay.
Jetzt haben wir wieder ein Jahr. Alles klar. Wisst ihr was? Ich lasse die Einheit einfach
weg. Ich lasse die Einheit einfach weg. Okay, so ist gut. So ist gut. Das sind Sekunden
bis es expired. Alles gut. Und jetzt versuche ich noch einmal was ekliges zu machen. Ich
versuche nämlich einen Graf anzulegen. In Zabbix für die Domains. Das würde ich normalerweise
nicht machen, aber okay. Graf, das ist jetzt das neue Graf-Widget von Zabbix. Domain expire.
Zehn Sekunden Refresh natürlich. Okay, also Host-Pattern, nicht Linux Server. Es ist auch
kein Hypervisor, aber ich hatte nichts anderes. Domains, Item-Pattern. Time left. Äh Moment,
wie mache ich da Wildcards? Wie mache ich da Wildcards? Weil ich weiß ja gar nicht wie
viele Domains ich... Was ist das hier für ein... Achso, das ist mein Hin und Her Gespräch.
Ich weiß ja gar nicht wie viele... Die Farbe, die Fault-Farbe sackt. Wie besser. Ich kann
man da Wildcards machen? Zabbix, Graf-Widget, Wildcards, Dashboard-Widgets. Nein, nein, nein,
nein. Für 6.2 Wildcard. Achso. Graf, Wildcard. Okay, da steht schon mal irgendwas. Was?
The Enter-House-Name-Items-Pattern. Data of items... Wildcard-Patterns may be used,
for example, Sternchen will return results that match 0. Just enter string manually and
press enter. Okay. Note how all matching houses... A list of items. Also, wenn ich das
jetzt richtig verstanden habe... Was ist das überhaupt für ein Seitenaufbau hier? MonkaS,
Alter. Geht es noch kleiner hier neben? Nee, das war was anderes. Okay, also wenn ich das
jetzt richtig verstanden habe, schreibe ich da jetzt rein. Domain... Nee. Expire, Time,
Left. Sternchen? Nö. Cutberry, Dankeschön für den Zapp. Warum erwachst du die Zertifikate?
Ich erwache nicht die Zertifikate, ich überwache, wann die Domain abläuft. Wann meine Domain-Registrierung
abläuft. Ich habe das genau gemacht. Domain, Expire, Time, Time, Left, Sternchen. Okay,
jetzt geht's. Genau das gleiche habe ich doch... Moment, ich glaube, ich war eben einfach zu
schnell. Leute, oh ist das schlecht. Wenn man zu schnell enter drückt, checkt der das Sternchen
nicht. Guck mal, ich muss Sternchen machen, warten, bis das Sternchen angezeigt wird und
dann darf ich Enter drücken. Na toll. Die Zabbix Leute. Aber ganz ehrlich, Grafen in
Zabbix sind schon ziemlicher Müll gegen Grafana, oder? Seriously. Guck mal, die Farben kannst
du kaum auseinander halten. Du kannst keine gescheiten Farbpatterns auswählen. Du kannst
doch nicht mal den aktuellen Wert anzeigen lassen. Also... Du kannst nicht die einzelnen
Dinge ein- und auspländen lassen. Also das ist wirklich nicht so nice. Wer braucht da
eigentlich eine Uhr? Viel unsinniger geht es doch gar nicht, weg damit. Problems. Problems
gibt es hier unten drunter, dass es wenigstens ein bisschen gescheit aussieht. Top Hosts.
Aber die besten. Nur die besten der besten an den Hosts sind das hier. Safe. Alles klar.
So, jetzt haben wir einen Zabbix-Graf, der nichts gescheites anzeigt, weil ich nicht
in der Lage bin, das in Sekunden anzuzeigen. Warum benutzen wir Zabbix? Weil ich daheim
einfach nur spezielle Hosts übermachen will. Klassische Dinge wie Ping und SSH da und bei
einzelnen Sachen zum Beispiel bei Zertifikaten ein bisschen History und Ablaufzeit haben
will. Weil mit Grafana Prometheus geht das auch alles, ist aber bei weitem nicht so schön
integriert, du musst sie halt selbst zusammenstückeln. Dafür ist die Config um ein Vielfaches schöner
als das in Zabbix. Und Grafana ist eindeutig das bessere Tool für grafische Visualisierung
als Zabbix. Jemand guckt euch das mal an. MonkaS. Okay, wir haben es geschafft. Leute,
es funktioniert. Zabbix discovert die Sachen und malt Grafen damit. Jetzt mal Frage an euch,
bevor ich off gehe, was futtern. Welche Config würdet ihr preferen? Die Prometheus-Grafana-Config
oder das Zeug aus dem Zabbix? Was ist dein favorite Mapstone? Das muss auch weg. Edit
Dashboard. Weg. Save. Oder generell, was ist euch als Monitoring System lieber? Ja, ich
auch. Ganz ehrlich, Prometheus-Grafana-Config ist deutlich angenehmer. Aber Zabbix ist halt
mal von der Config abgesehen die besser integriertere Lösung, wenn man darauf Wert legt und sich
nicht selbst zusammenstöckeln will. Leute, wie lange bin ich on? Ernsthaft? Ich bin
4 Stunden on. Und mach diesen Krempel schon? 4 Stunden 13? Meine Güte. Mich würde es aber
noch eine Sache interessieren, bevor ich was essen gehe. Wie sieht es bei euch auf der Arbeit
aus, falls ihr in diesem Umfeld arbeitet? Was benutzt ihr als Monitoring System? Habt ihr
vielleicht beides? Habt ihr Zabbix oder Nagios oder PRTG für klassische Sachen und Grafana
für Grafen? Manche haben zu viel Geld und haben Datadoc für ihre Cloud-Dinger und geben
irgendwie... Was kostet der Kram? 200 Dollar pro Note oder so? Wenn ihr mal kecken wollt,
schreibt es mir in die Kommentare. Wie viel kostet der Kram? Wie viel kostet der Kram?
15 Dollar pro Host pro Monat? Da muss man echt zu viel Geld für haben. Grafana plus
Kibana. Das heißt, ihr macht auch irgendwelche Elasticsearch-Geschichten? Ja, verstehe ich.
Für alle, die noch klassische Sachen einsetzen, mal eine Frage hier an Condor und an hier
Winkelino und alle, die mehrere Systeme haben. Legt das bei euch daran, weil in dem Fall
hier Checkmk und Zabbix quasi schon vor Prometheus und Grafana da waren, also sprich, weil das
die alten Systeme sind und man einfach noch nicht alles davon runterbekommen hat oder
weil ihr sagt, wir verwenden beide Systeme absichtlich, weil sie unterschiedliche Stärken
haben. Okay, wir haben ein paar Zabbix-User. Einen PRTG-User. Ganz ehrlich, ich fand das,
was ich von PRTG gesehen habe, bisher auch gar nicht schlecht, aber es ist halt Windows
Only und Windows Only kommt bei mir nichts in die Tüte. Ja, wenn es die Firma zahlt,
ist wurscht. Bei uns beides. Ja, wie gesagt, ich würde noch interessieren, also bei den
Leuten, die beide Lösungen verwenden, also quasi so klassisches hostbasiertes, checkbasiertes
Monitoring. Was ich halt für mich daheim an der Prometheus Grafana Sache etwas doof
finde, ist, dass man sich das so selbst zusammenstücken muss. Ja, also zum Beispiel, wenn ich
jetzt sagen will, ich möchte meine Server pingen, ich möchte SSH-Check machen, ich
will Festplatten-Auslastung haben, ich will Domains checken, Zertifikats checken, so
und wenn ich das in Prometheus machen will, dann brauche ich fünf verschiedene Note-Exporter,
kryptische Blackbox-Exporter-Config, wobei die geht, wenn man sich ein bisschen dran
gewöhnt hat. Ich brauche ein Jammel-File, wo ich meine ganzen Hosts drin verwalte. Das
ist halt so, was ich ein bisschen doof finde daheim. In größeren Umgebungen ist das weniger
das Problem, aber gerade bei mir daheim ist es halt im Zabbix-Host-Anlegen drei Templates
hinzufügen für Ping, SSH und sonst was ganz praktisch. Und ich habe halt bei mir daheim
auch kein Kubernetes-Cluster, wo ich sage, ja Moment, wir fahren jetzt mal drei, vier,
fünf neue Dinger hoch und die sollen dann automatisch metriken collected werden. Den
Verwendungsfall habe ich bei mir da heimlich. Das ist richtig, ja. Das ist richtig, wobei
du das im Blackbox-Exporter ja gar nicht machst, was wir eben im Zabbix gemacht haben, dafür
müsstest du einen eigenen Prometheus-Exporter programmieren. Sowas, was wir hier gemacht
haben. Wir haben ja hier einen eigenen Prometheus-Exporter für die Domains gebaut. Also sprich, bei Zabbix
ist die Komplexität halt schon irgendwo im Frontend und in der Config und beim Prometheus
ist die Komplexität eher in dem, dass man sich quasi seinen Monitoring selbst bauen
muss. So kann man es eigentlich sagen. Also die Grafana-Prometheus-Kombi ist eher, wir
bauen uns unser Monitoring selbst und wir nehmen halt fünf, sechs verschiedene Note-Exporter,
die wir brauchen, die konfigurieren wir, dann brauchen wir Inventory in der Jaml-Datei und
so. Da ist bei der Prometheus-Grafana-Geschichte eher die Komplexität. Wie gesagt, wenn man
das automatisiert hat und eine große Umgebung hat, dann sieht das anders aus. Aber bei mir
daheim ist es so, keine Ahnung, ich stelle mir jetzt einen neuen Raspberry Pi hin für
meinen 3D-Drucker und sage, hey ich hab einen neuen Host, der hat die IP und der soll Ping,
SSH und Festplatte checken. So fertig, Template hinzu, gut ist.
Auf der anderen Seite wäre das ja in Prometheus-Grafana auch nicht so das Problem. Was? Ist
Cloudflare adult-friendly für Blockhosting? I don't know. I was never in the situation
to host an adult-Block. But if they say themselves in terms of services, I think it's not such
a great idea. A few years ago every adult-Block was hosted on Tumblr. Gachi-Buzz.
Ja, das ist gut. Wobei selbst das, ich finde das ist tatsächlich nicht schlecht. Das Dumme
ist, du kannst Templates nicht Interfaces zuordnen, was teilweise ziemlich weird-champ
ist. Also zum Beispiel könntest du nicht zwei Ping-Templates einem Host zuordnen, wenn
er zwei verschiedene IP-Adressen hat. Was ich nicht verstehe, weil die haben die Beziehung
in der Datenbank schon drinnen stehen, die müssten einfach einen Dropdown dafür machen.
Was der Titel bedeutet, wir überwachen meine Cloudflare-Domains und zwar waren die Ablaufen
und ich rede jetzt nicht von den Zertifikaten, sondern wir haben einen eigenen Exporter programmiert,
was ich mir, ich kann es dir mal zeigen, ich kann mir jetzt die Zeit anzeigen lassen im
letzten fünf Minuten. So ich kann mir jetzt die Zeit anzeigen lassen, wie lange es noch
dauert bis meine Domains auslaufen. So meine Domains laufen beide in 52 Wochen aus. Oder
aber, das hier hinten ist übrigens verbackt, da sollte eigentlich die richtige Zeit drinstehen,
der Tag, wann es expired. Ja und das schöne daran ist, egal ob ich zwei Domains habe bei
Cloudflare oder 50, das würde der auch alles checken. Ja und den Graph könnte man deutlich,
wisst ihr was ich jetzt mal ausprobier? Eine Sache noch, bevor ich offge-edit. So wir nehmen
jetzt mal den hier und sagen noch mal neues Panel und jetzt, Matrix Browser, zack, Options,
Custom Domain, wir lassen uns jetzt noch mal was vorschlagen. Suggestion, was schlägt
ja uns denn vor, was wir hier machen können. Ok, Base Line Chart. Was ist denn jetzt? Macht
das wieder zu. Line Chart Smooth, alles klar, das ist jetzt Anti-Elased, POG. Ja es ist
eigentlich genau ein Jahr, es ist blödsinn was da steht. Dann haben wir Area Chart Stacked,
das 100%. Äh, nicht wirklich oder? Da gibt nicht wirklich Sinn was das da gerade anzeigt.
Kappa, Lul und Omega Kecke. Leute ich hab legit keine Ahnung, was mir dieser, was mir
dieser, ich nennt es mal Graf sagen soll. Was, was möchte mir Grafana damit mitteilen?
Keine Ahnung was das sein soll. Ehrlich gesagt, ehrlich gesagt wäre so eine Anzeige hier ganz
cool. Die sich ändert je nachdem, values, genau, die sich ändert je nachdem, wie viel
Zeit noch left ist. Das, Moment, das mach ich jetzt mal ganz schnell. Letzte, letzte
abends. So 52 Wochen. So und jetzt, haha, auf was geht das hier? Value Mappings, ne. Auf
was geht das hier auf? Geht das hier jetzt auf? Ne, das geht, das sind nicht die Values,
das sind hier die, das geht nicht auf die Sekunden, das geht auf die, das geht auf die
richtigen, auf die richtigen, also nicht auf die Wochen, sondern auf die Sekunden. Ja das
ist natürlich doof. Ich müsste, ich müsste das wirklich umrechnen in Tage. Leute, Pfeiffedder,
Pfeiffedder, wer ist, wer ist Hia-Q und sagt mir wie ich das umrechnen kann in Tage? Time
Minus, Timestamp Minus Time. So und jetzt, durch, so. Hey, easy. Falsches E-Mode. Easy
as Facke. Unit. Day. What? Day. Days. Day. Hallo, ich bin Day, aah. Monka ist Days.
So. 364 Days. Und jetzt kann ich sagen, ok, ähm. Moment, ne Moment, Bass. Warte mal,
Moment, ich muss es andersrum machen, das zählt ja nach unten, das zählt ja nach
unten, also. Ab 100, Ab, Ab, Orange, Orange ist es ab 100. Äh, ich mach jetzt mal 105
ist, ist links, ok. Also, das ist ja falsch rum. Also sprich, genau Bass, genau die Bass
muss rot sein. Und alles über, alles über 60 ist grün. Weißt ihr was ich mich frage,
es faded irgendwie so ineinander, oder? Also sprich, probieren wir das mal aus. Ok, das
sind 300. Hallo, was? 364. Äh. 363. Achso, ich dachte, man sieht vielleicht, wie nah
das dran ist an, an den, an den Sachen. Also sprich, ähm. Ne. Dass es quasi dann immer
weiter in die Farbe reinläuft oder so, so, so. Weil, weiß ich nicht, ob es das kann.
Wir müssen es ja nicht übertreiben. Also im Prinzip würde ich jetzt einfach sagen,
dass alles über 100 ist ok. Oder sagen wir, alles über 60 ist ok und das heißt, ab 60
Tagen wird es dann rot. Ja, das ist doch mal eine sinnvolle Anzeige hier. Da kann man
am wenigstens was mit anfangen. Time, Domains, Domain, Time, Left, Apply. Da kann man doch
jetzt am wenigstens was mit anfangen. Das ist doch mal ein ordentliches Panel. Was hat
sich nicht verändert? Hä? What? What? Und wenn ich mehr Domains hätte. Leute, wollen
wir mal was ausprobieren? Nur bei einer hat sich die Farbe. Wollen wir mal was ausprobieren,
wenn ich eine weitere Domain kaufe, ob sie sich dann automatisch edit? Ich meine, ich
will jetzt eigentlich noch mal sieben Euro ausgeben, aber Prime Subs haben sie ja bezahlt
quasi. Komm, wir probieren es jetzt schnell aus. Es läuft, es läuft. Ok, ich kaufe jetzt,
Jett, Jett, ihr dürft bestimmen, welche Domain ich kaufe. Wie gesagt, ich werde mir
diese Domain nichts machen, die ist nur zu Testzwecken. GetRektor.com, das klingt aber
schon ein bisschen nach. BoomerMüde kaufen wir. BoomerBettge kaufe ich jetzt. Gibt
es das? Voguege? Ich guck mal kurz. Voguege. Voguege. GetVoguege gibt es. Ok, da komm
ich aus Bettge. Bettge.com. Gibt es das? Bettconsulting.io schlägt es mir gerade vor.
Also Bettge.com ist schon, ist schon belegt. Komm, irgendwas, irgendwas. Was war da eine?
Voguege. Was ist das Scheiß? Voguege. Ok, GetVoguege.com. Meinetwegen. Ok. Ein Jahr,
ich kann nicht mehr, ich kann nicht, 8,57, 8,57 kostet es. Paypal, jawoll. Jaja. Paypal
Payn. Auf gehts. Es wird reingecashed Leute. Pay to Win sozusagen. Ok. Schauen wir mal,
ob die Domain hier gleich auftaucht. Sie ist noch nicht gekauft. Es dauert noch. Hier.
Ok. Fertig. Voguege.com ist gebyt. Schauen wir mal wie lange es dauert bis es hier drin
steht. Mal gucken ob es schon, wir gucken mal was schneller ist. Was? Not running? Gucken
wir mal ob der Zabbix oder Krafana schneller ist. Hosts, Domains, Latest Data. Voguege im
Krafana ist im Zabbix ist es da. Guck mal hier. Krafana checkt es nicht. Jetzt hat es
das Krafana auch mitgekriegt. So getvoguege.com und kappalolomegakel.com ist erworben alles
klar. Gut. Wunderbar. Und jetzt wissen wir Bescheid. Ich muss mir dieses Dashboard nochmal
runter kopieren. Das ist wirklich richtig cool geworden. Vim5head. Ich weiß dass es
mit gg geht. Aber es hat beides funktioniert. Beides hat autodiscovered und hier. Kann mir
irgendjemand erklären warum hier noch nix drin steht? Hier unten hat das erkannt. Hier
hat er auch Werte drin stehen. Refreshen sollte er sich eigentlich. Ach ich bin einfach nicht
weit genug rechts gewesen. Guck mal hier. Ich war nicht in der rechten Ecke. Da gab
es die Werte noch nicht hier an der Stelle. Also ich muss schon sagen. Versus Krafana
sieht das wirklich äußerst oldschoolig aus hier. Ich wusste dass irgendjemand jetzt um
die Ecke kommt und sagt null nicht rechts gelogen. Es war mir einfach klar dass das kommt. Ja
wunderbar. Leute wir haben es geschafft. Prometheus und Subbix Exporter am Start. Also Prometheus
ist schon ne ganze. Da kann das wirklich nicht gegen anstinken. Verwendet jemand von euch
weil wir gerade letzte Frage bevor ich was furtern gehe. Es gab ja mal von Influx DB.
Verwendet jemand Influx DB für so Metriken Zeug von euch. Weil es gab ja mal Influx
DB Kronocraft oder so. Es gab ja mal diesen Krafana Konkurrent von Influx DB. Das hat
sich aber nie so wirklich durchgesetzt. Versus Krafana. Das könnte ich machen ja. Wobei
ich halt sagen muss. Das habe ich auch gemacht schon. Das ist auch schon installiert. Also
nicht auf dem. Aber ganz ehrlich. Mir wird es strebt es halt zwei verschiedene Lösungen
zu haben. Die sich doch schon gewisserweise überschneiden in größeren Gebieten. Und
der Vorteil von Subbix ist halt ja eigentlich dass es eine schöne integrierte Lösung ist.
Und wenn ich jetzt den Subbix noch aus dem Krafana anzapfe habe ich wieder zwei verschiedene
Systeme. Und dann stellt sich halt die Frage. Warum nehme ich da nicht gleich Prometheus
und Krafana und mache das Monitoring da rüber. Und lasst halt. Basteln wir da noch ein paar
Nodexporter zusammen. Okay Leute. Letzte Frage des Tages. Hat euch der Stream gefallen?
Ich meine 4 Stunden 37. Jetzt irgendwie. Ich gebe es zu vielleicht nicht die spannendste
Thematik was das angeht. Aber ich hoffe euch hat es trotzdem gefallen. Und alle die Nöhe
schreiben meinen in Wirklichkeit ja. Sonst hätten sie jetzt nix geschrieben. Beziehungsweise
wären sie schon weg gewesen. Also es ist schön das ihr da gewesen seid. Wir hatten ja im Durchschnitt
wahrscheinlich 250 Zuschauer oder so. Gerade weil wir klicken im Monitoring herum jetzt
nicht unbedingt selbstverständlich. Ich werde jetzt was essen gehen Leute. Wir sehen uns
im nächsten Stream. Machts gut. Bis denn. Bett gespähter. Schlaft gut. Bis denn. Machts
gut. See you.